[Musique]
quand va sur bonsoir bonsoir pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle
thinkerview nous sommes en direct est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement ouais je m'appelle Florent
on a décidé de vous faire venir ce soir
parce que
vous avez écrit des livres concernant la
finance internationale
concernant aussi quelques hackers
concernant
tout qui contrôle la finance ou comment
ça se passe et vous venez de faire un
documentaire qui s'appelle better Thanos
[Musique]
et on va parler de tout ça pour
expliquer notre communauté quel est
quels sont les intrications entre la
jeunesse la finance internationale les
répercussions comment s'organiser qui
s'organise comment il s'organise on va
commencer par le côté finance
le siècle et en bande organisée pourquoi
vous avez écrit ce type de livre et
comment vous avez construit ce type de
livre
je suis obligé de vous parler de moi
parce que effectivement
voilà ouais non mais je voilà j'ai pas
je pense que j'étais pas parti pour
faire ça
j'ai grandi en France j'ai fait des
bonnes études j'ai été élevée
voilà une bonne petite de la
méritocratie française j'ai fait les
bonnes écoles HEC etc et à 24 ans
j'étais entrepreneur à New York
pas du tout dans la finance d'ailleurs
mais j'avais monté ma boîte c'était une
start-up pendant la première bulle
Internet quel type de start-up je
renseignais les grands groupes de
distribution sur les nouvelles tendances
de distribution donc c'était du
marketing en fait
et moi j'aime bien en fait chercher à
l'époque je faisais ça j'appliquais ça
aux tendances de consommation
et voilà j'étais vraiment bibronnée à
cette idéologie de la performance il
fallait que je sois jeter à New York à
24 ans dans la bulle Internet fallait
que je sois la plus belle la plus forte
la plus riche enfin j'étais vraiment
dans ce triple là
et dans un mode très très
entrepreneurial comme on permettait à
l'époque enfin souvenez-vous la première
bulle Internet c'était le côté magique
de enfin on entendait la jeunesse
toutes les boîtes avaient peur de se
faire ringardiser par ces jeunes en
basket qui allaient réinventer le monde
enfin c'était peut-être la dernière
allumette en fait ou la dernière espoir
et en tout cas j'ai eu une fenêtre de
tir génial moi à l'âge très jeune en
fait et donc je l'ai vécu très fort et
je travaillais beaucoup très peut-être
16 heures par jour et je sentais que il
y a quelque chose qui n'allait pas en
fait dans ce trip hyper capitalistique
et j'ai eu la chance et c'est étonnant
de parler de chance mais voilà j'ai eu
la chance de vivre le 11 septembre à New
York donc j'étais toute jeune j'étais
toute seule enfin j'avais une équipe etc
mais ça vous a fait prendre conscience
de la en fait c'est vous savez c'est le
mot que tout le monde enfin cette
jeunesse aujourd'hui utilise beaucoup la
bifurcation ben moi c'est arrivé très
tôt très et de façon comme une lame quoi
j'étais à New York ce jour là sur le
toit de mon bureau il y a rien qui vous
prépare à assister à ce genre
d'événements bon on l'a tous vécu mais
moi il se trouve que j'étais quand même
très très proche et encore une fois
j'insiste sur ce côté très frontal de
l'événement
et donc j'ai réagi comme tout le monde
avec beaucoup de peur beaucoup de
d'incrédulité j'ai passé tous les
scénarios dans ma tête je me suis rendu
compte j'ai essayé de justifier ce que
je voyais de façon débile genre il
tourne Godzilla enfin voilà vous savez
votre cerveau mais vraiment en marche
pour vous protéger de ce qui se passe
mais ce que j'ai ressenti surtout c'est
un énorme sentiment de honte
pour ce que j'incarnais et c'est comme
si c'était enfin les choses avaient
commencé à enfin c'est ces choses qu'on
avait projeté sur moi qu'il fallait que
je sois une bonne petite que je sois un
bon soldat que je gagne de l'argent que
j'ai que j'accapare tout pour ma
réussite personnelle c'est comme ces
trucs commençaient à un peu à glisser de
moi à se défaire
et en fait finalement depuis ce moment
là donc j'ai arrêté d'être une femme
d'affaires j'ai arrêté d'être dans ce
triple là etc c'est pas passé en 24
heures mais voilà c'est un chemin et je
me suis mis à douter de tout ce qu'on
avait raconté en fait
à l'école dans ma famille que j'adore
mais voilà toute cette idéologie de
l'époque de performance de cultes de la
personne enfin de la réussite enfin
qu'est-ce que ça voulait dire réussir sa
vie et je me suis dit en fait je
questionne cette honte avec cette
intuition c'est comme un c'est un
portail c'était ouvert pour moi ce
jour-là que si on nous envoie des bombes
c'est qu'on balance quelque chose qui
fait qu'à l'autre bout du monde ou
l'autre bout de la terre les gens pas
les moyens de réagir autrement par ça
que finalement voilà en fait il y a
certaines personnes qui utilisent le
mal-être des populations locales pour
aller en fait
j'étais donc à New York je me souviens
très bien de la couverture du Village
Voice qui a disparu depuis avec Isabelle
montrer que Manhattan se décrochait du
reste de la mairie parce que
souvenez-vous la façon dont les
États-Unis ont réagit c'est avec
énormément de violence l'a fait du bien
l'axe du mal la démocratie les gentille
de l'autre côté les méchants et je sais
pas il y a quelque chose en moi qui a
pas du tout accrue à cette histoire et
en fait je ne fais que creuser depuis
en me disant mais d'où viennent ces
bombes
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'on envoie au
monde qui fait que ça nous revient sous
forme de bombe et donc progressivement
j'ai quitté mon métier j'ai quitté ce
truc de regarder les tendances de
convention pour rendre les boîtes plus
riches franchement voilà mais je viens
de là
et je me suis mise à douter j'ai mes
parents vous diraient que j'ai
énormément déprimé enfin pour eux
c'était voilà
ouais peut-être peut-être et je me suis
mise à enquêter en fait et finalement
c'était une énorme
occasion vous savez les chocs les deuils
les maladies les catastrophes avec le
recul je me dis c'est aussi autant de
moments pour se demander qui on est et
c'est comme si moi j'avais eu
l'opportunité de me dire mais en fait
qui je suis quoi est-ce que je suis
cette nana vraiment à New York qui rêve
d'écraser son voisin qui veut s'acheter
un tel truc et qui fait les soldes le
week-end est-ce que vraiment j'ai envie
d'être ça quoi et j'ai eu je me suis
mise à me demander ce que je voulais
vraiment et finalement j'ai toujours été
très curieuse j'avais toujours rêvé
d'écrire et d'être journaliste et à
l'époque j'ai j'avais un petit ami qui
était à Kaboul et qui était
qui était là-bas pour pour reconstruire
l'Afghanistan parce que souvenez-vous la
communauté internationale disait
peut-être que il y a un problème
d'inégalité quoi et si l'Afghanistan
hébergé ou voilà peut-être qu'il faut
qu'on reconstruise ce pays vous avez pas
développé une haine du terrorisme ah non
quand vous allez quand vous avez été
Kaboul ah non qui a protégé
Ben Laden vous avez pas développé cette
haine non je crois que je suis beaucoup
plus naïve que ça
je suis allée à Kaboul avec la même
énergie que j'étais partie à New York 5
ans auparavant j'étais partie à New York
pour être riche et je suis parti à
Kaboul pour sauver le monde
donc toujours cette espèce de grande
énergie de grande naïveté en fait et je
me suis pris une énorme porte de saloon
quoi
je suis parti à Kaboul je travaillais
pour la Banque mondiale j'étais j'avais
un diplôme qui permettait de tout faire
et c'est ma grande chance en fait j'ai
fait HEC et
en fait je voyais j'étais embauchée pour
regarder et faire les contrats des
consultants internationaux qui venaient
de partout de la planète pour
reconstruire l'Afghanistan l'époque il y
avait 80 milliards de dollars qui
avaient été mis sur la table par la
communauté internationale pour
reconstruire l'Afghanistan et en fait ce
que j'ai vu
c'est le flow de consultants qui passait
du Soudan au Yémen à Kaboul à Haïti etc
qui venait empocher leur salaire de
consultant et leur perdière pour
reconstruire l'Afghanistan et qui en
fait attendait à la piscine de l'ONU
que les jours c'est cool qu'ils puissent
repartir dans l'autre sens et en fait
c'est là que j'ai vraiment en fait
autant le 11 septembre je pense que j'ai
parlé de choc post-traumatique je pense
que je l'ai pas eu là je l'ai vraiment
eu accabul où je me suis dit là je
comprends qu'en fait je comprends
vraiment qu'on voilà ce qu'on envoie en
fait qui est une énorme illusion qui est
une énorme gagie qui est un énorme
scandale
de ce que l'on fait au monde même quand
on dit qu'on le reconstruit en fait
et je suis rentrée de là en morceaux
pour un tas de raisons et ce qui m'a
sauvé c'est d'écrire et j'ai commencé à
à vouloir témoigner de ce que j'avais vu
finalement je passais de la start-up
internet souvenez-vous les valorisations
n'importe quoi enfin voilà c'est une
bulle de dingue peut-être des gens dans
cette chaîne qui n'ont pas connu cette
période mais c'était la folie et à
Kaboul
voilà à l'époque
où j'ai eu aussi peur en fait et ou si
j'ai j'ai croisé
voilà cette population et cette jeunesse
et ses femmes
enfin je sais même pas trouver les mots
quoi en fait
qui croise votre regard comme vous êtes
en train de le faire là et tout passe en
fait et
j'ai peut-être que je suis tombée un peu
d'amour pour ces gens-là en fait et
voilà enfin ça explique probablement ce
que je fais maintenant mais
je me suis je suis parti de cet endroit
mais mais j'ai eu aussi envie de
regarder ce regard là et de le raconter
donc j'ai commencé à écrire un premier
livre
donc personne n'a voulu au début et puis
j'ai eu la chance de tomber sur un
éditeur fabuleux
parce qu'au début j'étais parti sur une
jolie petite copie on est planté
pourquoi on est planté comment on s'en
sort quoi et je fais la tour de la place
de Paris avec mon livre personne n'en
voulait et un jour je suis tombé sur un
éditeur qui qui m'a dit vous oubliez
tout ça moi je veux que vous me
racontiez votre histoire à vous
et au début je voulais pas du tout
parler de moi et je me suis rendu compte
que c'était un manque de sincérité
et j'ai écouté cet homme là et c'est
devenu mon éditeur chérie et depuis on a
fait on a comique quatre livres ensemble
Olivier Frébault les éditions des
équateurs énormes
et
il m'a fait accoucher de mon premier
livre c'était ma première sage-femme une
fille dans la ville
qui a été
en fait c'est comme une planche de surf
un livre quoi et il est ce livre est
parti et m'a ouvert plein d'autres
portes
ça raconte c'est le principal enfin
c'est le seul livre vraiment
autobiographique où je raconte ce que ça
fait d'avoir vécu de New York à Kaboul
c'est le passage du 11 septembre jusqu'à
jusqu'à la réalisation de d'où ça vient
en fait
quand on est très jeune et quand on avec
un minimum de connaissances
macroéconomique puisque moi j'ai fait ça
j'ai j'adore la macro
et c'est néanmoins un roman très bon
de l'époque soi-disant
et donc j'ai commencé à questionner le
système tout ce qu'on nous avait raconté
le capitalisme etc ce livre a bien
marché et donc on m'a demandé d'en faire
d'autres et depuis je ne fais que
rebondir de livres en ville livre vous
savez on dit toujours enfin moi j'ai
vraiment le sentiment que chaque chose
que je commets j'arrive chaque chose à
laquelle j'arrive à aller au bout de je
sais pas si ma phrase est correcte mais
bon c'est pas grave on me pardonnerait
et le brouillon du truc d'après et en
littérature c'est dingue parce qu'en
fait vous vous
accouchez de quelque chose
et puis en fait il y a une autre porte
qui s'ouvre et vous tirez une comme une
pelote quoi et donc ce premier livre
c'est comment on passe du 11 septembre
enfin comment on passe de l'insouciance
totale de la bulle Internet où on se
septembre à Kaboul et à ce monde qu'on
est en train de sciemment détruire qui
gouverne ça c'est finalement ma grosse
question depuis toujours et
je me suis intéressé donc au pouvoir de
la enfin ce qui se passait en termes de
démocratie au pouvoir de la finance et
ça c'est mon deuxième livre
comment j'ai liquidé le siècle et
l'histoire d'un trader d'un
quantitativiste qui fait du flash
trading à la au crédit général et qui
décide de planter une un virus sur les
marchés financiers
pourquoi comment etc et ce livre a
cartonné parce qu'à l'époque on
découvrait tout à coup ce que Goldman
Sachs était en train de faire au monde
que tous les personnes qui venaient en
plateau de télé étaient des vieux mecs
banquiers et que tout à coup moi qui
avait jamais fait de finances donc ne
m'interrogez pas sur une équation du
second degré
j'étais capable en paraît-il de
vulgariser pour les gens ce qui est ce
qui était un marché et ce qui était en
train ce qui était en train de de
complètement rendre
l'été enfin le monde fou en fait et
pourquoi le projet démocratique était en
train de nous échapper donc ça c'est le
deuxième livre qui pose la question de
qui pose le point la finance pas pris le
pouvoir troisième livre
en bande organisée
parce qu'effectivement c'était facile ce
truc de la finance a pris le pouvoir
c'est facile enfin franchement j'enfonce
une porte ouverte quoi
la question c'est pourquoi je suis
d'accord avec vous et comment
et donc là j'ai fait une autre enquête
parce qu'à chaque fois c'est hyper
documenté donc j'ai de la chance
pour voir effectivement oui je
j'aime bien faire ça j'aime bien
ouais je fais des trucs comme ça je vais
au siège de Goldman c'est pas le plus
intéressant ce qui est intéressant c'est
de rencontrer les gens quoi et qui vous
confie ce qui savent parce qu'ils
pensent que vous pouvez en faire quelque
chose donc il y a toujours ce côté
confiance ne pas trahir faire le mieux
qu'on peut quoi et j'ai donc pour
comment j'ai liquidé j'ai travaillé avec
beaucoup de traders notamment qui m'a
tout raconté quoi et j'adore comprendre
en fait j'adore apprendre et finalement
après je relance que je comprends et en
bande organisée j'ai retravaillé avec
des des traders avec des hackers
cette idée du hack mettait venue avant
et m'étais venu vraiment de de comment
j'ai liquidé j'avais lu un truc qui
disait que le FBI une bouteille
énormément une attaque sur les marchés
financiers tout le monde s'en fichait et
moi ça m'a intéressé en fait et
voilà donc j'ai tiré ce fil là et
évidemment c'est une grande trouille
pour tout le monde mais sans le savoir
je
tombe sur des trucs quoi et donc sur en
bande organisée j'ai
je crois que j'ai eu une autre enfin je
pense que j'ai une intuition c'était
c'est un livre qui est sorti en 2013
que que finalement d'ailleurs c'est un
bouquin qui est jaune
je sais plus mais bon bref c'était AVANT
TOUTE le fait qu'on puisse élire
quelqu'un comme Emmanuel Macron c'est à
dire quelqu'un qui vient de la finance
et en fait ce livre quelque part prédit
un peu ça puisque c'est voilà c'est
l'histoire de 7 personnes qui sont la
même promo HEC que je connais bien parce
que finalement moi je vois mes potes mes
anciens potes de promo qui sont tous
dans les positions de pouvoir
et j'ai envie de leur dire mais
qu'est-ce que tu es en train de
fabriquer quoi donc ces gens-là je sais
pas qu'on s'engue parce que je l'ai je
les vois pas en fait et longtemps ils
ont eu pitié de moi et de mon chemin
quoi mais
je les regarde avec
enfin je les ai vu faire en fait
qui sont rendus compte
je crois qu'on est ils sont enfin les
les plus inféodés du monde quoi de à ce
dogme de toute puissance de croissance
enfin tout ce tout cette folie de croire
qu'on est dans un croissance infinie on
a tous les droits que il y a que le
système capitaliste qui puisse exister
que enfin
je crois que sur les pauvres
je sais pas si ils ont le courage de
regarder
mais je sens que ça s'effrite mais c'est
récent pendant longtemps il y a eu
énormément de
il y a comme une espèce de
difficultés enfin comme un ou par
laurier de clivage
un truc vraiment psychique qui qui coupe
en fait et c'est comme s'il y avait le
refus de voir le miroir et donc je pense
que ça justifie beaucoup de fuite en
avant donc toujours plus de fric donc
toujours plus de pouvoir dans toujours
plus de confort dans toujours plus de
et probablement toujours plus de
dissonance et de solitude donc enfin je
dis pas que que
enfin j'ai passé beaucoup de temps à les
dénoncer en fait j'ai ce Livre et m'a
amené énormément d'ennuis d'ailleurs
toutes les enquêtes que j'ai faites
emmener pas mal d'ennuis et surtout j'ai
envie d'insister là-dessus mais j'ai pas
complètement raconté le livre mais
en fait toutes ces années là j'ai broyé
beaucoup de noirs parce qu'en fait je
suis plongée au cœur du réacteur quoi
quand vous faites un livre avec cette
protagonistes principaux qui incarne
chacune des formes de pouvoir donc la
finance la pub la com la politique les
médias et que le point de ce truc c'est
de montrer comment tout le monde se
tient et comment tout le monde travaille
ensemble
je dis pas que j'ai que raison mais je
pense que j'ai approché quelque chose
qui est très dark et qui est très juste
il s'appelle en bande organisée et voilà
cette collusion au pouvoir comment on
glisse d'un commandement on a
commandement à quelque chose de
catastrophique je sais pas tous comme ça
non pas du tout et je pense pas que ça
soit nécessairement quelque chose qui
soit même consciemment voulu vous voyez
c'est pas il y a pas un dessin
maléfique je crois pas ces trucs là je
crois qu'en fait c'est cette idée de
confort et l'idée qu'on s'en sortira
mieux que les autres qui en fait fait
que sans s'en rendre compte
on aboutit à la catastrophe il y a aussi
cette histoire on parlait beaucoup à
l'époque vous savez tout faire il y a
cette conviction
d'aléa morale l'idée qu'en tombera pas
et qu'on s'en sortir pardon mieux que
les autres pour expliquer à nos
auditeurs et nous autoroutes to big
c'est une banque qui est tellement
grosse que si l'État ne renfout pas
c'est l'État qui tombe avec mais c'est
vrai je pense
et on l'a découvert en 2008 avec la
crise des subprimes mais c'est vrai de
la finance mais je pense que c'est les
vrais je pense que c'est vrai
psychologiquement de certaines personnes
de pouvoir en fait qui sont persuadés
qu'elles tomberont pas parce qu'il y
aura toujours
elles peuvent pas tomber parce qu'elles
emporterait trop de gens avec elle donc
cette histoire de cast en fait de
collusion au pouvoir de tout le monde
qui se tient qui est quelque chose que
moi j'ai ressenti je sais pas si j'ai
tort j'ai raison je l'ai ressenti
je l'ai écrit et je me suis rendu compte
que ça mendait extrêmement malheureuse
de faire ça en fait que ça m'apportait
rien en fait je pouvais peut-être avoir
raison peut-être mais ça me rendait
hyper Dark et je suis maman j'ai des
enfants
plus j'en étais plus j'étais dark
et je me suis dit qu'il fallait que je
m'équilibre que je que je fasse quelque
chose pour ma propre santé mentale parce
que c'était peut-être pas venu sur terre
pour ça quoi
et j'ai commencé à me dire mais en fait
faut que je me rapproche des gens qui
essayent de proposer des autres membres
qui essaient de c'est bien de comprendre
tu vois pardon
je fasse part dans ce monde du tout
essayer
je veux que tu me parles aussi daron
mais on y vient en hiver bien sûr on y
vient mais parce que tout ça c'est une
suite logique en fait donc je découvre
tout ça je tombe dans un trou et en fait
le point c'est de dire qu'à force de
brasser une matière noire tu le deviens
c'est un champ de force en fait ce
système
plus tu le critiques
plus il va utiliser ça se critique ta
critique pour se renforcer donc je me
suis dit ça servait à rien donc
pour m'équilibrer moi pour mon propre
intérêt personnel je me suis dit je vais
avoir besoin de me rapprocher des gens
qui proposent des autres membres qui
proposent des solutions qui comme moi
doutaient et cherchent mais qui essayent
aussi de
voilà de je sais pas montrer des chemins
des lumières des tu vois des phares qui
sont les phares dans la nuit et qui sont
les miens en fait
et j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à des
artistes entrepreneurs pour pour à
l'époque grâce à mes livres j'avais de
la place un peu dans la presse je
faisais des chroniques pour le monde
pour France Culture donc j'ai pu
commencer à raconter ces histoires là
ces gens-là
et je me suis rendu compte que ça me
faisait quand même beaucoup de bien
c'est là où tu trouves quoi donc au-delà
d'avoir raison là tout à coup pouf tu te
recharges en énergie
pas à l'abri de tomber sur des bonnes
idées et surtout des hyper belles
personnes et ça ça m'a mis sur un chemin
de rencontre de dingue quoi
parce que finalement
c'est comme une armée de l'ombre et ces
gens là se connaissent pas ils se
pensent qu'ils sont tout seuls alors que
il je dirais presque nous sommes assez
nombreux et ce chemin là m'a permis m'a
mis sur la enfin j'ai eu beaucoup enfin
non après j'ai eu énormément de bol quoi
il y a une des rencontres les plus
importantes de ma vie
il y a que des gens préparés
mais sur ce coup là enfin bon
j'ai été je pense comme
beaucoup de gens totalement estomaqués
par ce qu'a fait Julian Assange
dès 2010 enfin moi je tombe à la
renverse sur ce bonhomme enfin face à ce
bonhomme qui sort et qui a cette idéale
de justice etc pour moi c'était c'était
fou quoi donc avec mon éditeur chérie
non je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure on
décide de traduire un bouquin que Julian
Assange a fait qui s'appelle
Dreyfus et on je traduise bouquin on va
il est à l'époque en Angleterre avec un
bracelet à la cheville il est déjà été
enfin c'est le début de la descente aux
enfers quoi et on le rencontre je fais
une interview avec lui
et l'histoire à peu près s'arrête là
pour moi parce que
il y a quelque chose que je sens qui est
merci
j'ai un c'est étonnant le lapsus que je
viens de faire enfin l'acte que je viens
de faire parce que je panais c'est
sûrement très au clair avec ça et bref
je le rencontre je fais ce que je peux
et en même temps je sens que quelque
chose me va pas
j'écoute mon intuition qui est juste
féminine et je dis pas que j'ai tort je
dis pas que j'ai raison je travaille
avec mon coeur j'écoute essentiellement
que ça et peut-être il y a plein de gens
dans votre communauté qui seront pas
d'accord mais toujours est-il que j'ai
fait ce que j'ai pu et que je trace
et ça me met sur cette piste du hack que
j'ai déjà
mais encore une fois sans grande
connaissance informatique ni techniques
mais avec cette idée que
on peut avec la technologie renverser
des choses
quelques années plus tard
Édouard Snowden sort du bois et là je
retombe à l'envers devant la beauté de
ce monsieur qui met son corps en travers
de la route pour dénoncer ce que je
ressens depuis des années à savoir que
les États-Unis sont retournés contre
leur propre population
idem je rêve de le rencontrer mais bien
sûr qui je suis comment je peux faire
enfin voilà et là le coup de bol c'est
que je vais à une conférence
dans le sud de la France où je suis pas
censé aller inviter pour ce bouquin en
banc d'organiser dont on vient de parler
je suis pas censé aller à cette à cette
conférence
j'y vais je râle je monte dans le train
et là il y a un type que je reconnais
qui est l'un des plus grands professeurs
aux États-Unis qui s'appelle Larry le
SIG qui est le fondateur des créative
commons
c'est à dire un pionnier de l'Internet
je le lis depuis 20 ans enfin 15 ans
c'est un type qui tu vois tout compris
de ce qui était théorisé l'internet
libre il est une espèce de gourou pour
les hackers c'est un monsieur qui a
écrit un article extraordinaire qui
s'appelle codeslow donc quand tu codes
tu poses la loi donc pour qui tu code
et ce type est là devant un TG dans un
TGV désert il va à la même conférence
que moi et là ma vie joue un peu là
finalement je me dis bon j'y vais j'y
vais pas et je vais le voir et je lui
dis je pipote et je dis je suis
journaliste au Monde ce qui est pas du
tout vrai je sais qui non mais j'avais
quand même la possibilité d'écrire pour
eux il vient d'écrire un article qui
prend défense d'Edward Snowden je veux
rencontrer Edward Snowden et je vais le
voir et je lui dis je suis navrée de
vous déranger je sais qui vous êtes
est-ce qu'on a une heure de train
ensemble est-ce que je peux vous
interviewer sur Edward Snowden vous
venez de prendre position il est l'un
des seuls à se mouiller tout le monde
tout le monde le traite en traître et
lui il y va parce que parce qu'il est ce
qu'il est quoi
et donc on a cette
interview folle que j'ai bien sur pas
préparé que je voilà
c'est c'est voilà c'était là et à la fin
de l'interview donc on fait un truc sur
Snowden très bien et à la fin de
l'interview je lui dis ah puis je
voulais vous interroger sur quelque
chose d'autre parce que j'ai vu que vous
étiez lié
je voudrais vous interroger sur Aaron
soirée
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé parce
que
neuf mois avant
a décidé de se suicider et ça pour moi
c'était
j'ai raconté qu'il est mais c'était
un moment qui a fait écho pour moi avec
l'oncle septembre en fait en terme de
douleur
Aaron Sword c'était à quelqu'un que je
lisais à l'époque et un type qui avait
26 ans qui écrivait sur un blog qui
était un génie vraiment mais vraiment un
génie quoi et qui qui en fait était l'un
des seuls penseurs avec Larry d'ailleurs
dont il était prêchant très proche et
c'est pour ça que j'ai posé à des
questions à l'arrière à ce moment là
qui était convaincu en fait que
l'Internet était le web plus exactement
était né pour réaliser une prophétie qui
avait été théorisée par par un monsieur
qui s'appelle théière de Chardin qui
était un jury 8 paléontologue qui
travaillait en 1930 et ce monsieur a
écrit le phénomène humain
et c'était ce monsieur a raconté que un
jour il y aurait une technologie qui
permettrait à l'humanité de se retrouver
dans un cortex mondialisé qui
permettrait à l'humanité et à l'univers
de prendre conscience de lui-même
Aaron n'avait pas lu TR de Chardin mais
il était exactement
la personne qui était convaincue de ça
il était convaincu que l'Internet était
là pour libérer les foules pour nous
émanciper pour pour décupler
l'intelligence
il est né son pas enfin depuis j'ai fait
un bouquin sur sa mort quatre ans
d'enquête ce qu'il reste de nos rêves je
suis rallie rencontrer ses parents etc
donc voilà j'ai je peux raconter mais en
fait son papa
l'a fait grandir en lui était lui-même
codeur et il a mis devant dans la
première page de l'Internet et Aaron a 8
ans est tombé dedans et à 12 ans il
connait il avait fait un ancêtre de
Wikipédia wikipédia a sorti 6 mois plus
tard avec l'argent je crois d'une
certaine forme du web rose
et et Aaron n'a pas pu voilà bénéficier
de toute son idée mais pour dire qu'il
était dans la même lignée que timberley
d'ailleurs il n'est une sieste que de
travailler avec lui à 14 ans il bossait
avec lui et mit
il
me l'avait embauché comme expert donc
bien sûr à Ron avait arrêté l'école
enfin voilà et il travaille avec les
plus grands et c'est à ce moment là que
Larry le repère et qu'il le prend pour
qu'il crée l'architecture de Creative
Commons donc c'est à dire les premières
licences ce qui a permis aux droits de
l'Internet enfin des droits des des
créateurs sur internet de se développer
et je sais que vous l'utilisez nous-même
on l'utilise
bref tout ça c'est la même famille
politique
et
donc je savais qu'ils étaient proches je
reviens à l'arrière dans le train quoi
je savais qu'ils étaient proches mais je
savais pas à quel point et moi comme
débile je lance à l'arrêt qui m'avait
donc très gentiment répondu donc il faut
imaginer le prof d'Ava Harvard juriste
donc pas des mecs très drôles quoi très
calme
non non non mais il était il aurait pu
alors pour une tas de raisons il l'a pas
fait mais il l'a pas pu c'est jouer à ça
donc on est en 2013 Larry Aaron vient de
vient de mourir enfin ça fait 9 mois qui
s'est suicidé
probablement
propulsé par son décès Edward Snowden
sort du bois
le décès daronne
oui alors ce qui s'est passé donc Aaron
je vous ai je t'ai expliqué ça dans
quelle famille idéologique il était donc
c'est vraiment les grands humanistes qui
pensent que la technologie
l'Internet peut aider à émanciper
l'humanité
à 14 ans on est en
14 ans en 2001
il a six au 11 septembre et il voit le
truc sur tourner il voit immédiatement
que la technologie va se retourner
contre les populations il a 14 ans il
commence à écrire là-dessus Facebook
n'est sur le même campus il est il est
Harvard aussi enfin il m'a été avoir
séparée par une avenue
est inspiré des travaux d'arômes lui il
crée wild et pardon il crée pas wide il
fait il crée Reddit au même moment
dans un dans un bouge du MIT à trois
voilà et il part sur cette sur cette
ligne là en 2003 il est millionnaire
parce qu'ils ont revendu Reddit
Aaron a de l'argent il est millionnaire
il a toute la liberté de faire ce qu'il
veut et il dédie sa vie à défendre cette
Internet libre
il fait une série de choses il se met
derrière Elisabeth Warren qui est une
grande femme politique qui qui est
démocrate qui essaye de faire passer des
choses bien sûr elle y est pas arrivé
donc c'est l'homme de l'ombre de tous
ces gens là l'homme de l'homme bleu à
coeur au bon grand cœur mais c'est
vraiment
extraordinaire quoi je sais même pas
comment résumer sa vie tellement il est
génial quoi
et en 2007 sur le campus du MIT où il
est étudiant libre parce qu'il veut
rester proche de timberly parce qu'il
veut rester proche de la illicite parce
qu'il y a toute sa famille politique
il décide d'aspirer toute la base de
données enfin une partie de la base de
données d'un grand éditeur de
publication scientifique aux États-Unis
qui s'appelle ghistor
qui en fait
a prétenté les travaux de recherche de
tous les les grands scientifiques
américains derrière un système
d'abonnement et en fait Aaron en rage
du fait que la
recherche scientifique qui est financée
par l'État
devienne un produit d'une entreprise
privée et il en rage de ce truc parce
que son point c'est de dire que à
Calcutta en Afrique du Sud les
universités de n'ont pas les moyens de
se payer les abonnements distors que le
mit la Sorbonne etc ont bien sûr les
moyens de se payer donc les étudiants
n'ont pas n'en sont pas sur un pied
d'égalité pour accéder à ces trucs donc
il aspire la base de données voilà j'ai
un hack quoi par millions
et voilà elle en fait rien il en fait
rien
à ce moment-là le FBI lui tombe dessus
course-poursuite alors il le cherche etc
il met quatre mois à le trouver enfin
pendant 4 mois il aspire ce truc
route 4 mois en janvier
il le repère ils mettent des caméras ils
repèrent où il est et voilà
comment il fait il va faire comment il
fait exactement et il le course sur le
campus
de police machin poursuites à vélo les
trucs enfin bref il l'attrape menotte
pose de police il arrête
comme un comme un criminel en fait à
l'époque pourquoi et peut-être ça
explique que j'ai fait mon lapsus tout à
l'heure si je viens à songe pourquoi il
l'arrête parce que Julian Assange aime
le feu aux poudres et que l'un des
effets de ce qu'il a fait c'est que
n'importe qui qui travaille sur la
technologie à ce moment-là et considéré
comme une menace par les États-Unis
et Aaron est une victime collatérale de
cette de cette cabale qui est lancée sur
absolument tout votre point de vue c'est
absolument mon point de vue voilà je
ce que j'en déduis après 4 ans de
travail voilà vous pouvez me croire pas
me croire mais ça me brise le coeur en
fait parce que autant l'un comme l'autre
j'aurais tellement adoré qui réussissent
et vous le savez certainement mieux que
moi mais un vrai hacker il protège sa
communauté en fait
et la communauté le protège
et
Aaron bah je pense qu'il a pas été très
protégé pour le coup donc il tombe dans
un pour le coup un trou c'est à dire que
là le gouvernement américain lui tombe
dessus et notamment le gouvernement
qu'on adore soi-disant de Barack Obama
lui tombe dessus et la cule à un procès
avec un million de dollars d'amende 35
ans il est menacé de 35 ans
d'emprisonnement interdiction de toucher
un ordinateur à vie
une base de données pour avoir siphonné
une base de données d'articles
scientifiques financé par l'État d'en
avoir rien fait en fait ils ont peur de
son potentiel quoi
il l'arrête
dans tous les sens du terme c'est à dire
que Aaron n'est pas emprisonné mais il a
il fait plein de procédures il voit que
ses amis autour de lui
c'est ce qu'on disait la communauté le
protège pas vraiment
et en fait il paye ses avocats il se
ruine et plutôt que de demander à à
Larry ou à timberly il connaît tous ces
gens là de l'aider et bien il va se
pendre
et il se suicide le 13 janvier
dans sa chambre à Brooklyn
et je suis aussi allée voir sa chambre
et
cette histoire me brise le coeur parce
que je me dis voilà quelqu'un voilà un
enfant qui a voulu nous prévenir et en
fait on a préféré pas écouter quoi
et donc ça c'est l'histoire d'un à
l'époque je la connais bien moins que ça
et je connais beaucoup moins les liens
entre donc à l'époque en 2013 quand il
vient de le faire enfin neuf mois plus
tard mais je sens que pour moi il est
important de comprendre cette histoire
je suis dans le trip suicide ou suicidé
quoi je suis pas sûr je me dis mais
est-ce qu'il a été acculé et ce qu'il a
été poussé voilà je suis je suis dans
mon trip on nous laisse pas faire quoi
et donc je rencontre Larry dans ce train
qui connaissent nos deux enfin qui
travaille sur Snowden qui connaît à Ron
bien sûr je lui voilà je le convaincre
faire cette interview et la fin
d'interview comme une débile je lui dis
alors à Ron suicide ou suicide quoi
ouais et je vois
Larry qui vraiment le type le plus digne
du monde quoi vraiment
avec ça je vois ça ça
pomme d'Adam qui parle en vrac
et
il me dit je peux pas parler de ça quoi
arrête-toi tout de suite alors que le
type est d'une politesse incroyable
comme c'est ces Américains très bien
élevé
et il se met à pleurer devant moi il me
dit Aaron était comme mon fils
et là il me lâche je me remettrai jamais
de sa mort
et pour lui je vais mettre à marcher moi
je dis un bon marché qu'est-ce que il
dit j'attaque une marche à travers les
États-Unis en deux mois dans le New
Hampshire qu'elle est à un des états
clés pour les présidentielles pour les
pas pour les présentes présidentielles
pour les primaires américaines je vais
démarrer une marche et je vais traverser
cet état du nord au sud
pour dénoncer l'influence de l'argent en
politique car ce qui a tué à Rome et
d'ailleurs plutôt que faire ton truc tu
ferais mieux de venir raconter cette
histoire au revoir
et donc j'y suis allée donc voilà j'ai
pris mon sac à dos j'ai pris mes
chaussures je suis allée marcher avec
lui
on était 12 au début de la marche
il faisait un froid polaire et on a
démarré la hareng walk
donc malheureusement j'ai pas pu rester
plus de 5 jours mais c'était une
expérience moi en fait c'est la première
fois j'ai pris la route quoi
et dans le sillage de cet homme qui est
devenu un de mes plus grand ami quoi et
j'ai commencé à raconter cette histoire
raconter sa croisade après il a voulu se
présenter à la présidentielle américaine
en étant candidat à l'après à la
primaire démocrate pour dénoncer la
fleur de l'argent en politique le parti
démocrate lui est tombé dessus ils ont
changé les règles de de comment on dit
ça de ne pas d'élection mais de de
pas nécessairement d'investisseurs mais
ce qui fait qu'on a le droit de se
présenter comme comme candidat en fait
ils ont changé les règles pour qu'ils ne
puissent pas se présenter comme candidat
de la même manière que Hillary Clinton
etc ils ont très peur qu'il fasse de
l'ombre et Hillary Clinton donc ils
l'ont enfin le système
démocratique américain la jetée
et donc j'ai retrouvé Larry totalement à
plat quoi et on se disait mais qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire et je
revenais à ce moment là
d'une première rencontre que j'avais
faite formidable de mélatie on va parler
plus tard d'elle mais d'une jeune
activiste parce que pour le coup il
m'avait il m'avait mis brosné quoi ça y
est j'étais parti pour pour raconter
l'histoire de tous ses activistes en
fait et je venais de croiser la route de
Melati activiste de 16 ans à l'époque je
lui dis mais tu vois vous pourriez faire
une armée de l'ombre en fait toi mélatie
etc il faudrait qu'on aille voir Snowden
dit ouais on va aller voir Snowden c'est
quoi on va aller voir Snowdon et en fait
ils connaissait l'avocat moi
donc c'est vraiment le top 2 enfin voilà
parce qu'il y a plein il y a plein de
gens qui s'occupent des doigts mais
voilà
et c'est tout ça ces gens là cessent en
fait pour le coup et
c'est comme ça qu'on a pu débarquer
Larry birgéthaï on se détire donc
j'avais créé le écrit le portrait aussi
qui est une députée islandaise aussi
soutien de WikiLeaks et on est parti
tous les on s'est retrouvés tous les
trois à Moscou pour pour filmer cette
rencontre de Edward
Larry Bir guitare c'est un film pour
Arte qui s'appelle meeting Snowden
et c'était méga chaud
donc moi je crois que ce qui me protège
c'est ma naïveté
je te dirai que j'avais presque j'avais
la truie de rentrer en fait
ouais mais enfin j'ai la trouille de
tout mais c'est vrai que
c'était c'était fou quoi que et qui nous
ouvre sa porte
je sentais que cet homme là avec quelque
chose à nous dire tout le monde
l'interrogeait sur le système de
surveillance je trouve que c'était une
bêtise je sentais qu'il avait quelque
chose d'autre à nous raconter sur la
démocratie et c'était vraiment mon angle
le système de surveillance ce n'est que
l'écume des jours en fait c'est c'est
une conséquence c'est un symptôme
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière tu vois il
faut toujours s'interroger
la forêt l'oeil tu vois tout ça
ou la Lune et
donc on parle là-bas
on se rend bien compte que que c'est
chaud quoi
et en même temps on est obligé de
montrer pas de Blanche donc on dit
vraiment ce qu'on va faire donc il y a
plein de gens qui me disent ouais mais
s'ils t'ont laissé passer c'est qu'ils
se sont servis de toi peut-être mais
n'empêche que j'ai fait exactement ce
que je voulais quoi donc
et donc ouais qui t'a dit ça non mais
je sais pas tu sais je regarde pas
nécessairement mais voilà les
commentaires
enfin des journalistes en l'occurrence
jalousie j'en sais rien tu vois mais et
toujours est-il qu'on se retrouve là-bas
et
et moi je suis quand même une bleue quoi
tu vois
[Musique]
et en fait je me suis j'ai
il m'a dit quoi faire quoi il m'a guidé
pour que il soit safe
donc il y a eu plein de péripéties on
avait booké
non mais juste qu'est-ce qui est drôle
quoi tu vois on avait bouqué une une
suite on est tout installé et tout il
lui a dit mais Noé que je vais là on va
là et ça et donc c'est lui qui contrôle
tu vois et il sait ok enfin voilà
donc bien sûr certainement qu'on a été
suivi n'empêche qu'on nous a laissé
faire
c'est sûr que quand tu vas à Moscou pour
faire ce genre de choses tu t'intervies
ou pas tu
t'arrêtes pas beaucoup pour faire des
plans de coupe quoi on a profité on a vu
j'étais très heureuse de voir cette
ville je me suis rendu compte que alors
je sais il y a la guerre il y a tout ça
mais
bien sûr mais que je parle de la
population là je parle juste de la
population c'est nos cousins je me sens
beaucoup plus proche culturellement
de ces personnes que j'ai rencontrées
que la plupart des Américains que je
croise enfin voilà j'ai senti qu'on
avait des racines culturelles très très
proche donc à nouveau je précise je ne
parle pas des gouvernements je ne parle
pas des gens au pouvoir je parle de la
population qui est comme
characanon de ce truc quoi de toute
façon c'est tout ce qu'on est quoi et
voilà et et bien sûr il y avait des
mesures de sécurité de base enfin moi
j'ai voulu protéger une orage quoi et
mais je peux te dire qu'on a monté ce
film dans un
[Musique]
dans un studio de montage au
rez-de-chaussée dans une barre de HLM de
Villeurbanne et que personne n'est venu
nous embêter quoi personne
alors soit on est trop petit ce qui est
très possible soit tout le monde s'en
fout soit personne n'a le temps soit on
pense que ça sert à rien tu vois mais
enfin faut arrêter le truc de
enfin j'ai pas eu le sentiment de
prendre tant de risques que ça quand tu
dis que tu étais stressé de rentrer avec
tes rushs en France pourquoi bah j'ai eu
peur qu'on les pique quoi j'ai en fait
moi mon stress c'était les rush
je sais pas je sais pas je sais pas j'en
sais rien tu sais je
clairement on m'avait laissé faire je
voilà j'ai juste planqué des rushs pour
être sûr d'avoir des doubles en fait
mais Arte a été génial ton contact est
avant que tu partes pour te dire voilà
on a un message à faire passer ou
n'allait pas là-bas ou
non je crois que je suis trop petite je
crois que
[Musique]
jeudi soir je suis trop
ouais j'en sais rien moi je te dis ma
naïveté me protège je me
moi je travaille pas pour eux je
travaille pour aider les gens autour de
moi à comprendre ce qui se passe et à
faire en sorte que tout le monde sent le
même niveau de panique de ce que j'ai
senti sur mon toit du 11 septembre si tu
veux je n'ai rien à faire du reste en
fait
et c'est ça qui me guide et toujours
est-il que je finis ce film donc il est
sur Youtube Arte très gentiment la
libérer
ouais en fait c'est le je crois c'est
l'un des seuls endroits où tu es
totalement libre en fait peut-être là
aussi mais peut-être pas un seul mais
j'avoue que que je les ai trouvés très
chouettes et
donc on sort ce film et elle a sorti de
ce film je me dis mais voilà ça y est en
fin j'ai le truc qui vont faire que les
semblables c'est à dire les adultes vous
comprend que faut bouger là que
il est il est important de enfin comment
dire
non mais démocratie
parce que c'est pas seulement ce qu'il
dit
dans ce film ce qu'ils disent tous c'est
que on est coincé dans un système
qui fait que la parole est hyper limitée
qu'on ne parle plus des vrais sujets
qu'on est entretenu dans un système de
peur parce que ça contrôle ça permet de
contrôler tout le monde et que on est
tous responsables de ça que finalement
voilà c'est ce que
dans vigueur zanas des jeunes vont me
dire aussi finalement entre le confort
et l'humanité on choisit le confort et
ça a un prix terrible c'est l'humanité
et Snowden m'explique ça et parle de
cette démocratie américaine soi-disant
enfin voilà c'est à l'époque Trump vient
d'être élu donc c'est hyper chaud en
plus d'aller là-bas et
et donc avec ce film je me dis mais
enfin les adultes autour de moi vont
comprendre qu'il faut qu'on fasse corps
autour de ces gens-là qu'il faut qu'on
les protège qu'il faut qu'on un tout
petit peu si on peut pas être totalement
inspiré par eux qu'au moins en soi avec
eux et que on dit ça pour moi c'est
important quoi donc voilà je pars avec
ce film je fais des tournées
déjà j'ai beaucoup de mal à avoir
l'intérêt des gens et
quelques personnes qui voient le film
les adultes me disent ouais tu as raison
il est stellaire il est magnifique c'est
un moine soldat il a tout compris il est
vraiment au dessus du lot on devrait
tous être derrière lui mais tu sais quoi
moi je vais pas changer parce que
précisément je suis pas comme lui j'ai
pas ce niveau si tu veux j'ai pas cette
surface
psychique mental 700 ce sens de la
justice c'est c'est
cette espèce d'alignement c'est vrai que
c'est un moine soldat c'est vrai qu'à
mon avis
j'en sais rien mais je pense qu'il non
mais oui non mais ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que tu sais si ces gens bah
plus grands que la vie quoi Larry on
fait partie Aaron enfin c'est vraiment
une tradition tu vois c'est ces gens là
c'est très rare tu vois tu es vraiment
ils sont prêts à lâcher leur vie pour la
communauté quoi c'est très c'est
exceptionnel c'est exceptionnel j'ai eu
la chance de les voir tu vois et de
voilà qui me fasse confiance et je serai
jamais comment le remercier j'y pense
enfin vraiment je pense à lui tous les
jours quoi il y a pas un moment je me
dis qu'est-ce qu'il fait quoi les
adultes autour de toi donc les adultes
autour de moi me disent tu as raison mon
énergie ce que je dis mais moi je vais
pas changer parce que je suis pas comme
lui
donc là je me prenais énorme claque
parce que je me dis ça fait
16 ans que j'essaie de bouger les gens
et en fait ça marchera pas ça marchera
pas en fait les adultes sont programmés
ils ont peur de perdre ils sont ils sont
trop ils sont trop confortables donc
premier sentiment d'impuissance pas tous
trop confortables non mais les gens
que par capillarité
par capillarité moi je peux toucher tu
vois enfin je vais très franche j'ai
conscience de de faire des bouquins
difficiles de faire des trucs exigeants
enfin tu vois et c'est pas pardon je
voudrais vraiment pas dire que
enfin avoir un discours méprisant mais
j'ai conscience de
que ça fonctionne tu sais c'est je pense
que le changement c'est une personne qui
parle à trois personnes qui parlent à
deux personnes qui parlent à quatre
personnes qui parlent à 5 personnes et
tu ne vois pas ce système là enfin tu
vois pas la vague que tu crées tu vois
pas ce que tu déclenches mais n'empêche
que qui parle de ça
en fonction exponentielle du bien en
tout cas nous c'est aussi une scène du
film qu'on vient de faire mais c'est
très important de comprendre ça parce
que c'est très important de comprendre
que
la viralité c'est aussi quelque chose
qui
il faut que tu commences par convaincre
les gens autour de toi et puis après ça
ça tu peux espérer quelque chose mais si
tu comprends enfin si tu ne convaincs
pas le strict cercle immédiat
c'est compliqué avec toi
comment comment tu quel a été ton choc
psychologique quand tu as vu en fait qui
avait pas de lumière chez les autres qui
comprenaient pas tu t'es dit quoi c'est
moi qui explique pas assez bien c'est
eux qui sont très bannis ils sont pas
prêts à comprendre ils veulent pas
comprendre
psychologiquement parlant ça t'a fait
quoi mais moi je ça me foudroie de
détresse ça me foudra des tresses et
puis après j'en fais quelque chose moi
j'ai beaucoup de colère j'ai beaucoup de
tristesse j'ai beaucoup de chagrin mais
j'ai une chance énorme
c'est que
c'est autant de tu sais on dit l'encre
et noir
c'est
exactement tu vois c'est la plaie et la
question c'est qu'est-ce en fait la
seule question c'est qu'est-ce que tu en
fais qui tu as envie d'être
et ma grande chance c'est que grâce à
cet éditeur dont je te parlais tout à
l'heure il m'a donné une voix il m'a
donné une plume il m'a en fait les mots
me sauvent le travail me sauve et
et c'est
une planche de salut tu vois c'est comme
ça que je rencontre des personnes qui
m'inspirent qui me réveillent qui c'est
comme ça que je me lis en fait et je
crois qu'on a plus que ça notre capacité
à nous lier la capacité à faire corps
donc je sors de ce de cette expérience
avec un énorme sentiment d'impuissance
cela dit donc je te parle de la sortie
de meeting Snowden où je me dis [__]
je vais pas l'aider quoi
tu vois ça marche pas ça marche pas
et à la même époque j'ai mon fils de 7
ans
parce que j'ai deux enfants
qui a déjeuné me dit maman ça veut dire
quoi la planète va mourir
et moi je fais quoi pour qu'elle meure
pas et d'ailleurs toi tu fais quoi
et effectivement tu as raison sur une
question comme ça tu as deux options
soit tu dis mais t'inquiète pas mon fils
tout va bien maman est là mange ton
steak haché il est bio
soit tu sors tes rames et tu essayes
d'être là et de et d'expliquer à ton
enfant
ce que tu peux faire quoi est-ce que tu
peux ce que tu peux expliquer et là me
voilà dans une conversation qui est
probablement la plus importante de ma
vie
où je je me lance dans une explication
avec mon fils et je me rends compte je
vais te la faire courte parce que ça
dure 1h30
de l'angoisse de la planète qui tombe
effectivement parce que effectivement
merci
quand mon fils me dit ça je
comprends
inconsciemment qui démarre une écho
anxiété à 7 ans
et ça me pète à la figure en fait et
je me rends compte de mon impuissance
totale c'est à dire que je j'essaie de
lui expliquer en étant digne et pas de
prendre j'essaie de pas le prendre pour
un débile quoi donc je lui ai explique
tu vois comme je peux enfin de façon
extrêmement maladroite façon quand tes
parents mini cote et tes parents savoir
tort donc voilà déjà je me plante dans
toutes les largeurs mais j'essaie de lui
expliquer et je me rends compte que tout
ce que j'ai à lui dire
d'abord c'est très factuel si tu vois
c'est que des données qu'on dit on dit
la même chose depuis 30 ans c'est porté
par les mêmes experts et chaque chose
que je lui dis rajoute à son angoisse il
y a rien qui va le faire repartir je le
vois à sa tête tu vois qui à chaque fois
tu vois c'est comme si il sera tatiné un
peu plus
sur sur ces explications et à chaque
fois c'est et néanmoins lui je le vois
réagir
et à chercher une solution mais si je
fais si mais si je fais ça et je me dis
mais en fait c'est ça qui vous trouvez
c'est mais si je fais et si tu vois donc
je me rends compte que toutes les
explications que j'ai à l'époque sont
des trucs qu'on est éculés qu'on entend
depuis toujours que c'est porté par des
vieux mecs qu'on entend depuis 30 ans et
qui en a ras-le-bol et qu'il y a rien
d'aspirationnel et j'ai l'intuition que
en fait pour cette génération il y a
personne que les seuls à leur parler
c'est les quelques profs courageux
les marques et les parties d'extrême et
que sinon il y a personne qu'il y ait un
espèce de désert idéologique et que
c'est la catastrophe donc comme les
adultes ça marche pas et que pour les
enfants il y a personne
c'est pareil ça arrive pas en deux
secondes mais je me dis il y a un truc
là il y a un truc donc je sors de cette
conversation qui dure une heure et demie
en lui promettant en me pleurant dessus
que je vais vous faire un film sur la
pollution
à l'époque je travaille pour Arte il
repart à l'école je me jette sur un
moteur de recherche littéralement je
mets pollution jeune activistes et la
mélatie sort de mon écran et je commence
à regarder ce qu'elle raconte et je
tombe à la renverse et je fais un
premier film avec elle je vais à Bali je
la rencontre
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait à l'époque elle a
16 ans
et ça fait quatre ans donc elle a
démarré l'âge de 12 ans et ça fait 4 ans
qu'elle essaye de faire interdire les
sacs plastiques sur son île à Bali parce
que l'île est en train de crouler sur
les sacs plastiques et c'est une
catastrophe écologique c'est une
catastrophe
économique enfin voilà c'est c'est
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui réagit avec
son cœur etc et ça fait quatre ans
qu'avec sa sœur Isabelle
Isabelle elle essaye de de convaincre
les gouvernements sont gouvernement de
passer une loi je vais raconter son
histoire qui me paraît être l'histoire
parfaite pour mon fils voilà une enfant
qui se bouge à son niveau en local qui
est une fille totalement solaire
etc j'arrive là-bas et je tombe à
l'arrière parce que je rencontre une
femme jeune femme qui me raconte tout ce
que Snowden me raconte tout ce que tout
ce que Aaron représentait tout ce que
l'arridi ça sort du corps d'une toute
jeune fille de 16 ans par ailleurs
métisse avec une lucidité un calme de
façon tout à fait implacable et là je
pense à tous les adultes qui me disent
qu'ils bougeront pas et là je me dis non
mais attendez ok pour vous voulez pas
être Snowden mais vous avez été un
enfant aussi des enfants le vont
peut-être qu'en fin vous allez vous
réveiller quoi
et donc je me dis que cette histoire est
dingue et puis on s'entend enfin moi
j'adore les gens que j'interview en fait
en général je tombe amoureuse voilà
tu m'as comprise d'amour profond en fait
et
toute la vertu de ce métier
et hors caméra parce que parfaite si tu
vas elle connaît les Anglais les trucs
enfin un peu trop d'ailleurs et hors
caméra je dis c'est super merci
mais au fait tu vas comment quoi
et là c'est aussi
tu lui as posé cette question par
transfert du choc que tu avais pris toi
pour savoir si elle partageait cette
même souffrance quand en fait j'ai
l'intuition à l'époque je suis
exactement en train de travailler sur
l'histoire daronne j'ai écrit l'histoire
de Ron
enfin j'enquête
et je suis et je suis face à mélatie et
je me dis enfin tu vois il y a un côté
gémellaire quoi
voilà une enfant qui essaie de nous
alerter
et donc ça ça connecte avec ça tu vois
et je l'interroge et je lui dis donc
comment tu vas et là elle aurait pu me
dire tout va bien et là elle me fait le
don de me dire ça va pas
ça va pas je suis toute seule
et ça va pas assez vite et j'en suis à
mon deuxième burn out et j'ai 16 ans et
là j'entends Aaron si tu veux j'entends
Aaron qui s'est arrêté j'entends Haron
qui s'est suicidé et je me dis je me
fais la promesse là je peux pas je n'en
peux plus que des enfants je ne veux
plus qu'un enfant se suicide de ne pas
avoir été entendu donc mon fils il y a
Aaron il y a mélatie
et je dis à mélatie écoute
contre le temps je peux rien faire
personne ne peut battre le temps
mais je vais te prouver un truc c'était
pas tout seul
et donc elle me regarde quand même
demeurer et voilà que je que je commence
à réfléchir à ce film mes Girls qui part
de cette intuition là et de cette de ce
désir là de sauver la maladie
parce qu'en fait en faisant meeting
Snowden si tu veux j'ai fait quelque
chose pour Édouard quand même je lui ai
amené deux de ses potes
et en fait c'est ce qu'on a c'est la
rencontre c'est c'est les connexions
invisibles c'est ou visible mais tout à
coup c'est c'est ce qu'on peut se faire
les uns pour les autres c'est se lier
quoi et donc il y a ce truc de il faut
qu'elle rencontre d'autres comme elle
d'autres semblables et donc j'ai
l'intuition que simulatif et ça elle est
pas toute seule donc je commence à
gratter je vois qu'il y a plein de
jeunes qui se bougent c'est avant de
Greta elle est pas sortie du bois
et
senberg pardon
et on commence à lancer une enquête et
là c'est là c'est la boîte de Pandore
ils sont
hyper personne voit ça et les
journalistes les premiers quoi on est
toujours en train
d'interroger les mêmes experts qui nous
disent la même truc depuis 30 ans qui
nous servent à rien quoi
et
voilà et donc voilà et on part et on
fait ce film incroyable
ou on va croiser
on a Camille Étienne est d'ailleurs je
rencontre Camille à l'époque
qui est toute enfin qui est encore plus
jeune
et qui démarre
mais
bon voilà je la regarde en France flair
un peu
mais nous notre point c'était de faire
un film
sur la jeunesse mondiale en fait mélatie
m'avait presque convaincu enfin ouais
m'avait presque convaincu que j'aurais
pas le temps de finir le film
donc on a mis tous les curseurs à fond
quoi et donc notre point c'était de
faire un film sur la jeunesse mondiale
aujourd'hui 80% de la jeunesse n'habite
pas en Occident donc si tu veux faire un
film d'essence sur la jeunesse déjà tu
sors de ton vrai carré et tu mets une
caucasienne ou un caucasien à l'écran
Camille à l'époque démarre et en tout
cas moi j'étais sur d'un truc c'est que
c'est un documentaire c'est de l'action
c'est de la preuve c'est de l'impact
pour faire ça il faut des gens qui
soient pas en train de parler devant un
micro c'est des gens qui il faut que tu
vois une vraie arche ils sont cassés la
gueule ils ont démarré ils ont essayé et
je voulais des vrais victoires donc si
tu vas avoir de grands impacts il faut
que tu aies démarré il faut qu'il y ait
du temps donc c'est des gens et
d'ailleurs c'est leur point
d'hénominateur commun pour la plupart
ils ont démarré à l'âge de 12 ans comme
Aaron comme mélatie qu'est-ce qui se
passe à 12 ans peut-être un jour je
travaillerai là-dessus mais
et ils sont ils ont tous tu vois ils ont
changé des lois ils ont créé des groupes
de presse ils ont créé des écoles ils
sauvent des vies ils ont ils enseignent
à d'autres ils sauvent ils transmettent
ce qui savent tu vois notamment sur la
permaculture etc enfin on est dans
l'ultra concret du de la survie en fait
et c'était important pour moi de montrer
à mélatiques il y avait pas que
l'environnement que l'environnement
comme la surveillance de masse comme
les inégalités comme la perte
démocratique comme la condition des
femmes
tout ça c'est des symptômes d'un même
problème et qu'est-ce qui est important
aujourd'hui de comprendre c'est que tout
ça ça pointe vers la même cause racine
tant qu'on n'adresse pas la cause racine
on met des boots sparadrap sur une
hémorragie
et c'est la c'est l'essaye de enfin
c'est la démonstration qu'on fait dans
ce film parce que je voulais vraiment
que les gens comprennent que il y en a
ras-le-bol désolé les trucs il y en a
ras-le-bol et notamment dans le milieu
de l'activisme il y a beaucoup d'ego il
y a beaucoup de gens qui se tirent la
bourre ou tu vois le comment dire la
couverture à eux en pensant que leur
cause est plus important que leur cause
ben non en fait c'est une seule et même
planète c'est une seule et même humanité
et c'est un seul et même problème c'est
très simple en fait je dis pas que c'est
facile à résoudre mais c'est tellement
facile quoi à comprendre
et qui a pas de petites causes il y a
pas de petits il n'y a pas de mauvais il
y a pas de petites causes il y a pas de
mauvaise cause il y a pas de cause plus
importante les unes que les autres de la
même manière qu'il y a pas une seule
façon de militer tu vois dans le film il
y en a qui sont qui sont tous activistes
mais il y en a qui il y en a un qui a
lancé un groupe de presse au Brésil il y
en a qui
n'a commencé il y en a un qui a lancé
une école pour ces semblables des
réfugiés syriens en
au Liban quand il avait 12 ans il y a
une jeune femme qui a fait passer qui a
changé la Constitution pour que les
filles soient plus mariées de force à 15
ans au Malawi tu vois il y a la loi il y
a il y a les médias il y a il y a la
création il y a ce que tu peux faire
pour tes semblables de façon immédiate
notamment sur la question des réfugiés
et je voulais montrer que s'engager
c'est pas seulement magnifique quoi
et que ça et que surtout ça ça démarre
vraiment dans son cercle hyper enfin
c'est tout de suite et maintenant dans
ton dans ton ultra proximité quoi notre
génération on nous disait tu vas aller
faire des trucs dans des bidonvilles en
Malaisie
on a dit qu'on se balançait pas
c'est marrant je crois qu'on est plutôt
la même génération mais bon
mais tu vois ce que je veux dire on a
été
et en même temps c'est enfin moi je suis
un peu je suis totalement basculer mais
si tu veux je trouve que c'est quand
même une quelque part une un terrain
d'exploration et en démentation énorme
en fait qui est juste en bas de chez toi
quoi voilà merci pour cette introduction
on va pouvoir passer aux questions
maintenant
question basique que tout le monde va te
poser a déjà dû te poser mais vous avez
rendez pas compte Florent Vasseur vous
avez voyagé partout dans le monde et
vous avez compensé votre chargeur
c'est la partie fastoche
je crois ça à la compensation
non mais il y avait effectivement il y
avait la possibilité de pas faire de
film
ça c'est une vraie question je
[Musique]
j'ai la loutre cuit danse de penser que
pour bien raconter mon histoire il faut
aller sur le terrain il faut que je lave
c'est peut-être faux et c'est peut-être
mon dernier film mais tu sais quoi bon
voilà ce que alors on a fait un truc il
fallait checker quand on a fait une
campagne de crowdfunding pour ce film on
a 1200 contributeurs qui ont donné entre
5 euros et 10000 euros pour qu'on fasse
ce film et la seule enfin l'une des il y
avait deux il y avait trois gros goodies
tu sais on donne des compensations pour
en échange de 5 euros machin etc soit tu
avais des photos soit je t'envoie une
carte postale soit tu plantais des
arbres
et en fait on a grâce à tous les
contributeurs on a over super compensé
tout notre truc mais bon encore une fois
ça c'est de la gnognotte ce qui est
important quand tu fais un film le
problème de l'industrie
cinématographique c'est pas seulement la
pollution c'est que c'est un milieu
hyper misogyogène dans lesquels les gens
sont hyper mal payés donc moi il y a
dans mon équipe il y avait une
sur-représentation de femmes je m'en
suis pas rendu compte mais de la même
manière que les femmes sont sur
représentées sur les lignes de front
dans le film les gens qui ont tenu mais
avec enfin tu vois toute la rage qu'il
faut c'est les femmes les quelques
hommes qui sont qui sont les techniciens
qui sont coproducteurs le compositeur du
film ils assurent de dingue mais je peux
te dire que les seules personnes qui ont
quitté le navire
c'est des mecs
donc majorité de femmes majorité de
jeunes mon équipe était hyper jeune
bah parce que il y a une énergie une
joie une volonté de faire énorme et puis
que moi pas stage là quoi et j'avais
besoin d'une courroie de transmission
même si je pense que j'ai ce stage là
mais en fait je l'ai pas je le vois sur
les photos après parce que du coup je
dis mais
un bateau pour nous
dans le film
ouais parce que j'ai j'étais là
donc tu parles d'une scène où mélatie et
le personnage
lead pardon principal du film qui va de
pays en pays est en Grèce
dans un cadre absolument idéal
et tout à coup ben voilà on retourne la
carte postale et dans cet endroit
idyllique à une crique il y a des
migrants qui sont en train de se noyer
et Marie que à laquelle mais la tire
raconte toute l'histoire de son périple
est en fait sauveteuse en mer pour des
migrants et effectivement il y a ce
moment où elle sort de l'eau où elle
sort de l'eau elle saute sur son bateau
et tu vois ça fait partie pourquoi
j'adore le documentaire et ben voilà ce
jour là il fait 40 degrés on est épuisé
on est venu 4 jours filmer Marie pour
essayer de raconter cette histoire de
ces
voilà de ces jeunes qui sont venus
partout d'Europe et qui sont venus aider
les migrants à avoir une traversée safe
parce qu'à l'époque à partir du moment
où tu es passé dans les eaux Grecs le
droit européen fait que TCV et tu
rentres
en Europe enfin tu peux poser le pied en
Europe en tout cas et donc on raconte
cette histoire sauf que quand on arrive
pendant trois jours il y a pas de bateau
c'est calme plat mais pleine alors en
même temps c'est génial ça veut dire que
personne se noie en même temps c'est
terrible quand tu finis tu étais venu
que quatre jours pour tourner ça parce
que tu as rien à raconter donc moi j'ai
la chance sur ce tournage de prendre une
caméra enfin j'ai un directeur de la
photographie extraordinaire qui dès le
premier jour m'a dit tu fais tes images
donc il m'a donné un truc plus simple
que ce que vous avez peut-être trois
positions quelqu'un me la règle et moi
je pars et en fait je me régale mais du
coup je tourne tout le temps et je les
lâche jamais et ce moment là dans l'eau
c'est le moment détente
elles sont dans l'eau et effectivement
quelqu'un arrive et dire Marie a un
bateau et la maille devient toute
blanche et moi je suis en train de la
filmer et j'ai ce moment voilà c'est là
c'est un détail c'est la gloriole perso
mais voilà
une question le dénominateur commun et
tous ces gamins comment ils font pour
mise à part le côté opératif qui passait
comme quelqu'un qui se réfugie dans le
travail comment ils font pour encaisser
la sollacer quand il voit une famille de
réfugiés syriens des marqués sur leur
côte que ils ont été volés par le mazout
dans leur canaux pneumatique quand
celui qui va prendre des risques dans la
forêt équatorienne ou on Amazonie
comment ils font pour gérer pour pas
faire un burn out rentrer dans une
dépression ultra profonde et comment ils
font pour ne pas prendre les armes c'est
là ensuite ma question la deuxième
partie de ma question c'est
on parle beaucoup d'écoterorisme ou de
violence avec les écologistes
premièrement comment
comment
ils font pour gérer la ce côté
angoissant de la réalité de notre monde
et comment ils font
pour pas prendre les armes alors sur ta
deuxième question je ne sais pas te
répondre je suis navrée sur la première
merci de pointer ça du doigt d'ailleurs
ça me fait parler enfin ça me permet de
te donner une stats trois quarts des
humanitaires
ont des
séquelles
psychologiques grave et il y a personne
enfin tu vois il y a pris en charge par
personne en fait
donc ça c'est ça c'est un vrai truc dont
on parle jamais je peux te parler là
c'est le chiffre mais moi je vais te
parler de ce que je sais donc c'est à
dire de ce que je connais c'est à dire
de ces personnes là de ces sept là donc
je peux ça pas valeur c'est pas un
échantillon représentatif j'ai
conscience d'avoir
interviewé si tu veux enfin pour moi
c'est mes maîtres maintenant tu vois ils
sont même au rang que Snowden que Larry
enfin c'est ma tribu c'est ma famille
c'est des gens que j'écoute j'écoute
j'écoute personne mais je les écoute eux
donc j'ai conscience que tu vois c'est
ils ont quelque chose de tout à fait
exceptionnel pourquoi
ils tiennent
c'est la même chose en fait
je crois qu'il y a ce
il y a cette verticalité en fait que
j'ai retrouvé chez Snowden que j'ai
retrouvé chez
chez Larry et que peut-être Aaron
n'avait pas encore parce qu'il était
trop jeune
il y a vraiment cette idée qui sont
connectés à quelque chose de plus grand
que
il y a vraiment cette idée que ça passe
par eux
qui sont un outil de quelque chose qui
sont un véhicule
et c'est ça qui leur donne la force de
continuer ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième et on en parle jamais assez
il y a une forme de joie via une forme
de joie énorme d'être à sa place d'être
utile tu sais dans le film 5 des
protagonistes sur 7 ce sont mis à agir
parce qu'il fallait survivre on n'est
pas du tout dans le discours du bon
sentiment on n'est pas du tout dans je
suis de bon côté de la barrière et j'ai
des privilèges et il faut que je fasse
quelque chose dans cinq cas sur cette
dans mon film on n'est pas là-dedans on
est dans je vais mourir et je me
survivre donc on est à l'os de
l'engagement tu vois d'ailleurs l'une
des grosses questions c'est est-ce qu'il
va falloir qu'on attende d'être dans
cette situation là de gravité pour enfin
comprendre qu'il y a moyen de s'élever
quoi qui a intérêt à s'élever et pas
seulement pour ces histoires de sauver
l'humanité mais juste pour une question
dignité tu vois ça va ça va c'est plus
prosaïque que ça
et donc eux ils sont dans un rapport à
la vie qui est qui est pas le mien en
fait enfin je les fais bien parce que je
pense que je suis un papier buvard et
j'ai de la chance d'être dans cette
sensibilité là tu vois c'est c'est
chouette d'être ultra vulnérable en fait
mais
enfin le problème c'est quand on a peur
en fait que tu deviens fragile mais ta
vulnérabilité c'est comme c'est comme
les larmes c'est comme en fait je pense
que que les gens fragiles c'est ceux qui
ont peur de leur peur
et
tu vois bon bref je reviens je m'égare
mais pourquoi ils tiennent je voulais
parler de la joie
donc
ils ont agi donc 5 cases sur 4 7 parce
qu'il fallait survivre parce que c'est
une question de vie ou de mort pour eux
ce qu'ils ont découvert c'est quand on
se mettant à survivre
et ben ils se sont liés aux autres ils
ont trouvé une place ils ont trouvé un
rôle ils ont une utilité ils ont une
communauté
qui les aime et que eux aiment
et ça tu vois réfléchis mais qu'est-ce
qui nous donne dans la vie l'occasion de
vivre ça quoi dans nos villes demeurer
là où est-ce qu'on a l'occasion d'être
tellement
ancrée en fait et donc on a tourné il y
a 3 ans on est en contact quasi
hebdomadaire avec eux
toujours là-bas ils ont ils ont survécu
au covid en confinement aurait pression
tout est en train de flamber tout est en
train d'empirer mais eux ils sont là et
le fait d'être
d'être en lien enfin je sais pas comment
te dire d'être profondément connecté à
ce qui se passe
c'est pas seulement que c'est bien
et tu vois tu la gentillesse de me faire
parler de mon parcours et tu t'as bien
compris que il y avait eu quand même
deux trois chocs et deux trois crises et
de trois larmes et deux trois gouttes
donc j'étais pas parti pour faire un
film sympa tu vois je pense pas qu'ils
sont sympas d'ailleurs mais j'étais pas
parti pour faire un film
enfin moi j'étais parti pour faire un
film sur le sang la sueur et les larmes
de l'activisme tu vois pour tu vois tu
vois on est réveillé vous quoi
en fait
ce que j'ai vu c'est la joie ce que j'ai
vu c'est ce que ça veut dire d'être
vivant en fait
ce que ça veut dire de choisir l'amour
ou sur la mort
quand tu marches dans les rues
maintenant tu sais c'est un peu comme
quand tu reviens d'Inde la première fois
tu rentres en France ton regard a changé
sur le sur l'humanité qu'est-ce que ça
te fait toi de voir par exemple à Paris
des gens qui courent partout qui se
disent pas bonjour là c'est les grèves
il tape dessus dans les embouteillages
qu'est-ce que ça te fait toi alors j'ai
longtemps été en colère tu as
l'impression de voir des zombies ah mais
non mais moi j'ai écrit sur les
morts-vivants donc
bien sûr
mais je vais te dire deux choses mon
point de vue personnel c'est j'ai
longtemps été en colère
en rage en mode secouez-vous quoi et
maintenant ces gens-là font enfin j'ai
énormément de peine en fait
la peine puisque j'ai
justement c'est ça non mais voilà moi je
suis triste pour eux je me dis mais
quelle tristesse en fait j'ai de la
peine pour des gens qui qui en fait sont
son châtain tu vois c'est comme c'est
éteint et tu sais je pense pardon mais
bien sûr
bien sûr ils sont pressés par
l'employeur la dureté de la vie par
l'inflation par des politiques qui leur
racontent émerveilles qui se passe pas
ça ils sont pas respectés ils sont ils
sont ils sont à essayer de déguer du
quai leur gamin
tu as tout à fait raison
et ils font ce qu'ils peuvent tu vois
donc c'est pour ça que je te parle c'est
pour ça que je te dis c'est plus de la
colère pour moi c'est de la peine je
vois je vois la tu vois je vois le
en fait chacun fait comme il peut quoi
et moi j'ai pas le temps de et puis
enfin tu vois c'est pas une énergie que
j'ai envie de déployer de
cette énergie de rage en fait j'ai plus
envie de me demander encore une fois ce
que j'en fais mais je voudrais te
j'ai besoin d'un peu de contexte parce
que je voudrais pas que ça soit mal
interprété mais
je voudrais te raconter ce que m'a dit
moi Mad qui tu sais tous les
protagonistes de films à
positivement me hante de la même manière
que Edward Snowden me hante que Aaron me
hante enfin tu vois quand tu commences à
tellement rentrer dans le cerveau des
gens
tu les manges un peu tu vois ce que je
veux dire ça devient une partie de toi
et
moi je suis un peu partie mais voilà
tant pis
et moi Mad donc c'est un
enfant syrien enfin il a 20 ans
maintenant
qui a fui la série avec sa ses parents
parce que sa mère était professeur
et a été totalement parmi les premières
à manifester contre Bachar el-Assad elle
a été emprisonnée deux fois torturé
et la troisième fois enfin quand ils ont
quand ils l'ont libéré ils lui ont dit
si on chope une troisième fois on te tue
quoi donc ils l'ont ils ont décidé de
fuir la mort dans l'âme ils sont
installés à helmarch qui la ville
frontière avec le Liban
théâtre vol d'oiseau de la frontière
enfin tu étais à 1 km quoi ils sont
installés là elle elle en bouge pas elle
dit toujours je vais être la première à
revenir je suis à un jeu de pierre du
dictateur quoi tu vois et donc on a
démarré le tournage du film par le Liban
qui est un pays que je connaissais pas
grosse claque et le premier le premier
jour on se retrouve
balancé dans le camp moi j'avais jamais
été dans un camp je te dis ma naïveté
ça me protège parce que quelque part j'y
vais quoi tu vois c'est je suis pas en
train de me dire ouh là là je vais avoir
peur quoi j'y vais où je vais avoir mal
parce que là ça fait mal et là tu vois
tu vas dans un camp et tu as tous ses
enfants partout quoi
et à l'enfant qui part à l'école et le
pire tu as l'enfant qui est regarde
l'autre enfant partir à l'école et lui
il va pas
et tu vois bien que dans son regard il y
a toute la tristesse de dire moi je m'en
sortirai jamais quoi
et donc on fait cette séjour de tournage
ça se passe très mal le Liban parce que
les clips on se connaît pas on se taise
moi je sais pas bien ce que je cherche
j'arrive pas à les faire parler entre
enfin chez toi c'est le crash test il y
a toujours un tu vois c'est le pilote
quoi et on se viande toujours et c'est
très utile et moi Mad est quelqu'un de
enfin je rencontre beaucoup de gens
intelligents mais si tu veux là là c'est
vraiment
tu vois c'est la première fois
d'ailleurs quand je l'interview quand il
m'écoute il sait donc il écoute ma
question il est tellement concentré il
est tellement focus je vois la mort tu
vois c'est un espèce de je vois tout ce
qu'il a vécu quoi enfin bon bref c'est
un personnage et en même temps d'équipe
tu vois il est il est pas sympa tu vois
mais tu vois que c'est quelqu'un qui a
vu la mort et qu'il est intraitable sur
ce qui se passe mais il a 18 ans quoi
enfin
donc déjà enfin j'en ai à chair de poule
rien que de temps parler et je lui dis
Mohamed je sens qu'il y a un truc que je
chope pas là qu'elle doit être ma
position à l'égard de ses enfants parce
que moi j'arrive avec ma blancheur de
peau ma caméra mais chaussures mon fric
attends tu vois tu as abîmes totalement
le biotope tu viens tu vois tu
t'inquarnes quelque chose toujours cette
histoire de qu'est-ce que tu incarne
quoi
et j'en peux plus de ces journalistes
qui arrivent tu vois
exactement ah c'est bien gentil tu vois
non mais
je suis très en colère contre ça et je
me dis le respect que les gens
comprennent pas de travers ce que j'aime
bien
sur le zoo ouais mais on dirait plus
parlons de cirque dans ce cas-là mais tu
vois c'est pour bien préciser ce moi ce
dont je veux parler c'est cette idée que
en tant que journaliste souvent on croit
que notre histoire est plus importante
le reste et on maltraite les gens qu'on
filme ou le maltraite les gens dont on
raconte l'histoire il y en a marre de ça
c'est très intéressant que tu dis
raconter l'histoire parce que des fois
les journalistes ils partent déjà avec
leur histoire dans la tête mais c'est là
où je puisse écrire un journaliste
tu vois je raconte des histoires et
l'histoire est d'autant plus belle que
je suis au plus proche de la vérité de
la personne et de ma vérité sinon je
plaque un truc et c'est faux et c'est
superficiel et d'ailleurs ça tient pas
quoi ce qui tient le temps c'est
vraiment l'authenticité quoi et je crois
et la sincérité bon bref et donc je dis
à Mohamed s'il te plaît explique-moi je
me sens très mal à l'aise et pourtant je
veux faire ce film
quel est qu'elle doit être ma position
quoi et il me dit écoute ce que tu peux
faire
c'est déjà alors c'est un challenge pour
moi qui suis tellement émotive c'est ne
montre jamais rien donc tu tapis toi pas
tu si tu es dans tu vois dans un camp tu
montres pas par ton regard partager Ceel
que tu peux être triste à tirer choqué
et que tu peux dis surtout tu te gardes
de toute pitié tu te la gardes
montre l'heure qui sont forts montrent
leur que tu les admires montre-leur que
que c'est eux qui savent
et si tu veux c'est je pense que c'est
le conseil le plus puissant qu'on met
jamais donné parce que même tu vois
finalement même pour le film jamais on
va se poser en position tu vois on va
avoir une caméra descendante regardez
cette jeunesse trop mignonne non non
c'est pas auteur c'est dessous donc on
est allongé par terre à quatre pattes tu
vois pour toujours être dans l'espèce de
non seulement la noblesse de de
nos protagonistes et leur beauté
mais de ces communautés quoi de ces gens
qui savent survivre avec rien tu parlais
de dignité tout à l'heure et de et de et
tu vois de ces personnes qui essayent de
survivre ici avec tout ce qu'on leur
balance de peur de trucs faut que tu
aies peur faut que tu vois
je comprends que on se revoit dans la
consommation et dans le divertissement
je comprends la question c'est comment
tu arrives à te déconnecter ces gens-là
comment tu tu arrives à réfléchir et
c'est le bol c'est le boulot là c'est le
job donc
et on est d'accord que c'est pas très
facile mais Mohamad donc je voulais te
parler de ça parce que ça c'est le
premier truc qui me dit
qui est très fort et qui est pas dans le
film et la deuxième chose qui me dit
très forte sur cette sur ces zombies
dont tu parlais etc il me dit un truc
qui hors contexte est incompréhensible
donc encore une fois on est dans le camp
et lui et quelqu'un qui a réussi à avoir
un asile politique en Suède depuis il
est en Suède il a repris des études il
faisait des études de relation
internationale en même temps il bosse
pour Oxfam en même temps il tient son
école
au Liban qui pour ceux qui ne savent pas
c'est une organisation qui qui essaye de
lutter contre la pauvreté dans le monde
etc et
toujours est-il que Mohammad en plus de
ses études en plus de tout c'est des
gens qui font ce qu'ils font
en douce c'est si tu veux ils en vivent
pas quoi donc ils sont toujours en train
de bricoler quelque chose et je pense
que son job dans une ONG permet de payer
son activité pour sa propre école au
Liban qui est en train d'imploser
et moi Mad me dit je lui dis alors ça te
fait quoi d'être en Suède quoi tu vois
la Suède pour un réfugié c'est c'est le
c'est le rêve en fait quand tu es sur
les bateaux quand tu te dis enfin le
paradis l'école la sécurité la santé la
protection la fin de la guerre d'abord
la Suède et le troisième exportateur
d'armes dans le conflit syrien
donc tu vois il me dit et la deuxième
chose qui me dit surtout il me dit mais
tu sais ce qui me choque énormément
c'est que je vois plus de gens
dépressifs et éteint en Suède qu'il n'y
en a dans les camps en Occident c'est
comme si tout était fait je pense qu'on
vient dans le cœur du sujet
pour que la jeunesse soit désactivée
et je pense qu'il a raison et moi c'est
ce que j'ai vu et d'ailleurs c'est ce
que je vois tous les jours parce que
depuis avec ce film en fait donc on est
sorti il y a un an au cinéma machin etc
il a une vie assez atypique ce film
depuis un an on en est à 4000
projections citoyennes donc
essentiellement les profs se servent du
film pour pour inspirer les enfants pour
d'abord parce qu'on ne parle les
objectifs du développement durable et
qui effectivement c'est son programme de
la cinquième à la terminale oui on a eu
le patronage de l'éducation nationale
qui a dit ce film est important
utilisez-le on a eu un sponsor
incroyable qui a offert cent mille
places pour cent mille jeunes quelqu'un
qui a décidé parce qu'il a dit mais tout
le monde doit avoir ce film enfin on est
hyper aidé je sais pas pourquoi comment
ce film trouve son chemin et du coup ça
me donne la chance quasiment tous les
jours d'aller en salle de cinéma ou en
classe rencontrer la jeunesse de ce pays
les questions qui te posent c'est quoi
après projection
bon alors il y a la question évidemment
qu'est-ce que je peux faire
donc ça c'est enfin je ne sors jamais
d'une salle sans qu'il y a eu ça
qu'est-ce que je peux faire
[Musique]
il y a toutes les questions que tu m'as
posé comment pourquoi machin etc mais
vraiment là c'est la question de mon
fils
souviens-toi la planète va mourir dans
son langage d'enfant qu'est-ce que je
peux faire
le qu'est-ce que je peux faire et en
fait c'est la seule conversation qu'on
devrait avoir et maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'on fait quoi tu vois on peut passer
on peut passer toute la vie qu'on veut à
essayer de décortiquer le truc à pointer
du doigt la responsabilité de machin de
truc je l'ai fait très bien ça sert à
rien
la question maintenant c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait quoi et du de l'enfant au
prof au chef d'entreprise aux politiques
à ce truc à l'industrie c'est la même et
seule unique question donc il y a cette
question qui sort de l'enfance des
enfants il y a en fait tu sais ce qui
est génial c'est que plus les enfants
sont petits plus enfin plus c'est du bon
sens mais tu sais des fois je rêverais
que des journalistes viennent pas pour
piquer les idées mais pour comprendre en
fait combien la question des enfants
sont fortes combien il leur arrive pas à
la cheville quoi tu vois et ça ça me
donne vachement d'espoir tu vois c'est
que quand tu as quelque chose ou un
moment est-ce que c'est la vertu d'un
film ça c'est la vertu de l'art je crois
de l'art à un moment c'est que
aujourd'hui on a tous les concepts on a
toute la théorie on a tous les chiffres
on a même toutes les images donc on est
là ce qu'on a pas c'est le coeur on a
déconnecté totalement le cœur cerveau et
l'avantage d'un film c'est qu'il
reconnecte à ton cœur il te reconnecte à
ton émotion et qu'il y a un moment où tu
tombes la garde et que tu es plus le
boss de le député de le prof de machin
T1 adulte et un parent tu es un être
humain tu es quelqu'un qui a un temps
limité
oserais-je dire que c'est pas la
première fois
ce système est ultra intriqué on a des
fonds de pension qui sont censés
garantir d'air très pour des vieux à
gauche à droite sur la planète Terre on
a des systèmes économiques qui sont
intriqués avec des forces de travail des
impôts des matières premières de la
consommation énergétique de gaz de on
voit dans la géopolitique que le gâteau
se réduit comme peau de chagrin que sous
des prétextes d'apporter la démocratie
pour les petites filles on sécurise des
bassins énergétiques on sécurise des
routes d'approvisionnement sécurisé des
mines non sécurisé tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour continuer le la gabegie
parce que cette gabegie permet d'avoir
une subordination de vote je je résume
peut-être trop trivialement
passer à l'action ça veut dire
déstabiliser le système actuel
un effondrement qui peut-être serait
néfaste pour notre cohésion sociale à
très court terme même si je provoque
exprès même si
l'effondrement climatique écologiques
planétaire nous amène exactement vers la
maison
tu parlais des causes mais tout à
l'heure et je t'ai dit que j'étais
incapable de te répondre tu te souviens
et je vais pas repartir là dessus mais
je pense que c'est la même question en
fait finalement est-ce qu'on est
condamné à la violence
et je vois moi je veux te dire je pardon
mais mais
c'est pas ce que j'ai vu
en fait si tu veux ma grande chance
c'était être allé dans des endroits où
la société s'est déjà effondrée et où
elle n'a jamais décollé Brésil les
favelas
Malawi Ouganda tu vas dans le tu vois
dans les bons lieux white trash de
Boulder là où tu sais où ça pue le
piasser
non mais tu vois le enfin je pense que
plus personne ne se raconte l'histoire
sur les États-Unis mais bon là tu es
dans le dur de tu vois ok le Liban la
Grèce tu vois alors la carte postale et
puis derrière tu vois enfin la Turquie
apporte
et bien dans ces endroits où la société
c'est déjà effondrée il y a une humanité
qui veut vivre
et qui veut survivre et elle le fait pas
par la violence elle s'organise entre
elles et je peux te dire que les liens
qui les tiens c'est des liens d'amour
alors tu vas me dire ouais mais
peut-être que la violence était avant et
ça ça comment dire c'est sur un terreau
de violence tu as vu le film on n'est
pas dans le monde des bisounours deux
fois merci
on n'est pas dans le monde des bisous
d'ours tu vois que le décor est méga
dark mais même sur cette décharge je
peux dire que j'ai jamais autant joué
qu'avec les enfants de ce village si les
enfants courent partout à un moment
c'est parce qu'on court derrière eux
parce que tout le monde se marre
et donc je
pour pour je sais pas si c'était
exactement ta question est-ce qu'on fera
l'impasse d'un effondrement de nom
est-ce que ça va être violent oui est-ce
qu'il y a autre chose à vivre oui
et la question c'est c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire et la deuxième c'est
question c'est qu'est-ce que vous avez
envie d'être est-ce que tu as envie
d'être cette personne qui jusqu'au
dernier moment se met des œillères parce
qu'elle peut profiter de son confort et
avoir la dernière goutte de lait chaud
tu vois de ce moment là où est-ce que tu
as envie de commencer à
à rejoindre ton groupe quoi c'est Marie
fine qui dit en fait on fait ça parce
qu'on va rencontrer nos semblables parce
qu'on va faire corps parce qu'on va
vivre une aventure donc moi je te
garantis pas les grands soirs alors pas
du tout
va vivre une aventure
bah écoute c'est
moi c'est ce que je vis
et j'aurais pu te raconter peut-être la
même histoire en te parlant de
dépression de choc post-traumatique
mais n'empêche que je me sens vraiment
vivante quoi mais vraiment quoi et dans
et dans ce dans ce climat là je pense
que c'est ça qui c'est ça qui est en jeu
est-ce que tu as décidé d'être un
mort-vivant
ou est-ce que tu as décidé que que toi
et moi c'était pareil
qu'on était tous liés qu'il y a une
seule et même histoire qu'il y a une
seule et un seul même corps s'il y a
quelque chose qui nous l'a dit c'est
quand même la covid quoi
si tu étais malade j'étais malade si
j'étais malade tu étais malade tu sais
cette idée de séparation tout ce qu'on
disait tout ce dont on parlait au début
en disant la finance est assise sur
l'idée qu'ils vont s'en sortir mieux que
nous non mais là il faut vraiment être
frappadingue pourquoi pourquoi qu'on va
se pouvoir se barrer sur Mars tu vois
merci de finir ma phrase mais tu vois
c'est
je vais dire non mais
personne n'y croit tu vois sauf eux mais
enfin je veux dire voilà mais donc
s'il y a eu un moment où on a pu
comprendre qu'on était
on était tous et même un même truc tu
vois c'est ça et je pense que tu vois
l'une des questions les plus brillantes
que j'ai eu c'est une enfant de 12 ans
il y a trois semaines qui me dit mais
madame quel serait la valeur à changer
pour que tous ces fonds
12 ans tu vois parce que je disais parce
que ça c'est aussi s'effondre pas ouais
tout ce truc s'effondrent en fait tout
ce système capitaliste s'effondre et
qu'on passe à autre chose quoi ouais
enfin bon tu m'as compris
et tu as raison merci de refraser et tu
sais dans le film c'est suite escale qui
disent ça donc escale suite escale c'est
un c'est un enfant qui a démarré je
commence à être fatigué démarrer à l'âge
de 6 ans
et qui depuis l'âge de 6 ans dénonce
l'industrie pétrolière et les forages et
notamment le fracking aux États-Unis
donc le gaz de schiste il a eu des
menaces de mort à l'âge de 12 ans enfin
voilà il est devenu rappeur il fait un
rap extraordinaire hyper engagé ce type
est
fou quoi enfin et puis il a toute la
sagesse amérindienne donc il arrive avec
la sagesse des peuples premiers et tu
vois tu
as rien à dire quoi tu appuies sur ON et
s'il y a rien acheté quoi
et suite escales dans le film dit le
problème c'est que il est dans un décor
magnifique
au dessus des montagnes au dessus de
bouledogue et il dit tout ce que tout ce
qu'on a tout le problème c'est qu'on a
appris que ce qui a derrière nous et
nous c'était deux choses séparées
et que et qu'on n'était pas tu vois que
c'était que c'était distinct quoi et
qu'on pouvait du coup faire tout ça tout
ce qu'on voulait à ça que ça n'aurait
aucun impact sur nous mais il en est
dans même de la nature il en est de même
des êtres humains toute cette histoire
de séparation de l'homme et de la nature
qui a justifié donc c'est des cartes on
revient loin mais qui a justifié que on
puisse
polluer préempter accaparé violée la
terre les femmes c'est la même idée de
séparation si tu remets ça en cause tout
de suite tu comprends que ce qui arrive
à la nature c'est c'est ce qui t'arrive
à toi en fait tout de suite tu comprends
qu'il y a pas une crise écologique et
une crise peinture que tout ça c'est la
même chose qu'on est un seul et même
écosystème en nous et à l'extérieur de
nous
et que tant que tu as pas touché à cette
valeur tu vois cette idéologie de la
séparation qui a justifié le capitalisme
c'est à se partir de ce moment là qu'on
a mis des clôtures tu vois qu'on a mis
la propriété privée qu'on a commencé à
prêter les choses
tu vois quand je te dis il y a un côté
très simple quand tu touches à ça bah
peut-être c'est très compliqué mais tout
à coup tu comprends qu'on a intérêt à
faire corps et aussi cette idéologie de
la violence
je comprends qu'on en passe par là mais
c'est pas un truc que je enfin que en
tout cas je pense que tu ne verras pas
le faire
moi non plus
je vais te poser une question
tu es pas obligé d'y répondre
au changement tu crois qu'on va y
arriver
alors je vais répondre à ta question en
disant que je me pose pas la question
c'est pas le sujet
je te redis la question c'est
qu'est-ce que tu as envie de vivre
qui t'a envie d'être
quel regard tu portes sur les politiques
françaises européennes et mondiale
alors c'est là que je suis moins tendre
mais c'est fastoches donc c'est quoi
j'ai même pas envie d'en parler
longtemps ça m'intéresse pas trop
donc tu cherches tes mots jolis
commandant ma soude l'afghanas
tu vois pour moi les ce que finalement
merci parce que tu vois pas finalement
merci merci parce que finalement tout ce
dont on parle aujourd'hui depuis le
début de cette conversation c'est de
très grandes politiques
là il est ici Edward Snowden
Bir guitare
Aaron Sword art mélatie chacun des
protagonistes pour moi ça c'est de la
grande politique avec un immense P c'est
à dire les affaires de la cité être
capable de mettre son corps en travers
de la route pour le bien de la
communauté pour le bien commun j'ai
l'impression que cette perception de la
Politique
n'existe plus et en tout cas et il est
complètement antinomique d'une logique
électorale électoraliste un jour j'ai
rencontré une fille géniale je vous
invite à regarder son travail et
formidable elle s'appelle Adélaïde
Charlier c'est l'équivalent de Greta et
de et de Camille en Belgique elle a mis
de 1000 et elle a mis des millions de
jeunes dans la rue et je me plaignais
l'année dernière quand je la rencontrais
de pas avoir de politique qui organise
de projection je te donne deux chiffres
enfin trois chiffres aujourd'hui il y a
il y a eu 4000 projections citoyennes
auto-organisée du film
il y en a eu 13 par des politiques
voilà et donc j'enrage un peu
bien sûr tu vois qui
l'envita je sais pas si tu sais ce que
c'est l'envita c'est une Asos incroyable
des mères qui sont tous en mer
émailleurs qui sont tous engagés pour
pour la pour l'accueil digne de réfugiés
tu vois c'est des gens comme ça qui se
bougent là tu en parlent de gens au
niveau local qui sont les mains dans le
cambouis avec une situation qui explose
qui impose et
et donc je me plaignais quand même
auprès de Adélaïde en leur disant en lui
disant mais tu sais les politiques
est-ce qu'on peut faire ni mais
t'inquiète pas ma flore
les politiques c'est des followers
donc perds pas ton temps à essayer de
les convaincre et à essayer de faire en
sorte qu'il t'écoute va plutôt c'est
quand même ce qui quoi alors Macron a
fait la même chose va bosser les enfants
là jeunesse les profs tu vois prépare
les gens essaient de faire en sorte que
entre nous on s'organise et d'ailleurs
mais latine il a même chose dans le film
ça a tellement mal il faut qu'on
s'éduque les uns les autres c'est pas
l'école qui va te dire ça c'est pas ton
entreprise qui va te dire ça c'est pas
bien sûr un homme politique qui va te
faire ça on est tout seul alors il y a
des gens comme toi tu vois il y a des
sentinelles à droite à gauche mais
grosso modo on est tout seul il y a un
deuil à faire tu vois et c'est très
triste etc bon moi ça va je les fais bon
mais il y a un deuil à faire et quand tu
l'as fait c'est ok maintenant après tu
te bouges tu vois mais malheureusement
et à ce moment là à passer question
Internet
HEC dans une ONG à Kaboul un salaire
sûrement autour de
215 annuels
[Musique]
qui écrit un livre pour se
déculpabiliser de sa propre situation
alors là merci
ça me fait tellement alors
mes petits secs
comment dire je suis très à l'aise pour
répondre à ça
j'ai eu la chance de faire HEC ça m'a
donné tout sauf un salaire parce qu'en
fait pour moi c'est un ticket pour la
liberté en fait et pour faire exactement
ce que j'ai envie de faire
je me sens pas coupable d'avoir fait des
bonnes études et je me sens pas coupable
de faire des bouquins et de créer ce que
je peux par contre j'ai dédié ma vie à
ça je gagne le même salaire qu'elle a
sorti d'acheter c'est-à-dire à peu près
35000 euros
et j'ai fait très attention à pas gagner
plus parce que je veux pas être
prisonnière de mon confort alors ouais
j'ai les moyens et je trouve les moyens
de faire des films mais tout ce que je
gagne je leur ai investi dans dans ce
que je crée en fait et c'est ça ma
liberté et d'être juste à flot pour
pour pour être libre en fait et
la preuve Emma et
je pense qu'effectivement on est
prisonnier de notre confort
mais j'ai la prétention de croire alors
peut-être 35000 € c'est beaucoup pour
plein de gens mais que je suis pas
prisonnière de mon confort
question internet
bonsoir la team que pense fleur du film
don't lookup sommes-nous définitivement
perdu dans un milieu informatif du néant
ouais ouais bien sûr
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à le regarder ça
m'a gavé
parce que c'est notre monde
enfin voilà
j'ai pas la télé donc et j'ai plus
Netflix
mais voilà si tu allumes la télé c'est
donc le cap tu vois enfin pour moi je
comprends même pas que les gens
continuent à regarder en fait
maintenant ça m'a énervé parce que
autant de moyens
autant de fric autant de stars
pour lancer un message de on va pas s'en
sortir je trouve ça criminel ça m'a
vraiment agacée
et ça me permet de mettre un petit coup
de boule ou un gros parce que ces
plateformes là auquel certainement la
plupart d'entre vous
sont abonnés font un travail de sape
absolu
je trouve tu me donnes la parole donc je
vais pas mais c'est mon point de vue
mais c'est aussi mon point de vue de
réalisatrice et productrice c'est à dire
que
de toute façon ils m'ont dit non donc je
suis très à l'aise pour le dire
clairement
ce genre de films bien sûr
le message c'est je vais je suis bannie
à mort pour Netflix pour la vie entière
je m'en fiche oui mais bon voilà je
raconte pas l'histoire
mais je peux alors
voilà clairement
pas été retenu sur Netflix parce que il
considère que ce genre de contenu n'est
pas pour leur viewers leurs abonnés que
et tu vois j'en ai la voix qui tremble
mais que tellement je suis en colère
mais que leur point de vue c'est que ce
qu'ils veulent développer c'est
c'est des histoires qui sont directement
ancrées dans le quotidien des gens dans
de l'ultra proximité
considère que ce qui se passe à l'autre
bout de la planète n'a aucune connexion
n'est qu'un lien avec ce que les gens
vivent ce qu'ils veulent c'est faire
l'arnaqueur de tinder
c'est un documentaire qui sont très
fiers d'avoir fait et ils ne disent que
voilà leur modèle c'est ça c'est à dire
que c'est les considérations du
quotidien si tu veux c'est c'est c'est
te parler de des outils que tu utilises
et d'essayer de te montrer en quoi
éventuellement cette manipule etc ou pas
d'ailleurs mais grosso modo
non mais certainement certainement mais
je te dis tu m'as demandé de parler dans
le CUP je t'ai dit ce que j'en pensais
et je te dis que je pense que ces
gens-là ont la main sur nos cerveaux
aujourd'hui que c'est toujours la même
histoire qu'avec le la canette de coca
ou je sais plus ce qu'elle disait
moujotent à l'époque enfin tu vois sur
cette cette idée d'avoir les cerveaux
disponibles d'ailleurs Netflix si je me
suis pas trompé va mettre de la pub on
en est toujours à ce truc là l'idée
c'est d'attaquer votre cerveau
maintenant pour que vous ne puissiez
plus dormir
c'est pas moi qui le dis c'est une
phrase du fondateur donc si tu veux je
pense qu'il faut être conscient de nos
outils tu sais c'est cette phrase de
Herbert
l'écrivain de Dune nous sommes les
outils de nos outils à partir de quel
moment tu te rends compte
de quel est ton outil
question Internet
bonjour comment
demander aux populations de s'engager
lorsque vous-même avez eu besoin de
venir sentir et vivre les luttes au
niveau mondial pour pouvoir tenir ce
discours actuel cette expérience
est-elle pas paradoxale
alors je demande pas aux gens de
s'engager je dis juste que l'engagement
c'est une formidable façon de vivre sa
vie
et que c'est probablement la seule façon
de rester à flot et en santé mentale en
bonne santé mentale aujourd'hui que
c'est probablement le seul moyen de se
sentir un rôle décent aujourd'hui il
s'engager c'est pas forcément
faire la révolution s'engager c'est la
première chose et tu m'as pas posé la
question donc je voudrais le mettre là
pardon si ça vous paraît un peu hors
sujet
la première chose c'est à l'intérieur de
sa famille et là je vais mettre je vais
être en colère
je vois des enfants tous les jours
il y a pas un an il y a pas une
projection dans laquelle je ne sors pas
dans laquelle il y a pas un enfant qui
me dit Madame
jamais mes parents ne me parle de ça
s'il y a autant de quoi anxiété tu m'as
je vais donner deux trois chiffres vous
tu te souviens probablement tu as vu
passer cette étude de the landset sortie
en septembre 2021 sur comment va la
jeunesse aujourd'hui
75% des jeunes considèrent que sont
extrêmement pessimistes 58% considèrent
qu'on est foutu
les cabinets de petits déborde n'est
aussi débordent les taux de dépression
moi je fais des câlins des cachetons
merci de moi je fais des câlins tu ne
n'as pas idée du nombre d'enfants que je
prends dans les bras à l'issue des
projections ma question c'est où sont
les parents qu'est-ce que vous êtes en
train de faire quoi
et si j'ai c'est une intuition c'est pas
tu vois mais je me dis que l'écho
anxiété c'est pas seulement
l'accumulation des mauvaises nouvelles
c'est pas seulement tu vois et là on est
servi quoi on est d'accord on est servi
c'est le silence des adultes c'est pas
seulement l'inaction c'est le silence
des adultes donc l'engagement bah tu
vois c'est ce qui s'est peut-être mon
premier engagement c'était pas
rencontré Snowden c'était peut-être pas
aller au carton et et
elle est en Afghanistan
c'était dur d'aller en Afghanistan tu
vois c'est pas je suis pas allé là-bas
un business class enfin tu vois faut
arrêter les délires quoi c'est dur
mais bon oublions quand bien même tu
vois quand bien même oubliant mon cas
personnel
je l'engagement c'est avec la discussion
la plus importante à partir du moment où
je me suis vraiment engagée c'est la
discussion avec mon fils en fait
c'est ce moment où j'ai décidé de me
dire je vais sortir de mon piédestal là
mon diplôme achec qui sort à strictement
rien sinon à peu près à me dire que si
jamais ça va mal je pourrais toujours me
caser dans une boîte c'est vrai c'est
mon privilège c'est vrai
et c'est super structurant pour moi
parce qu'en fait c'est des personnes qui
prenaient soin des autres
et tu m'as fait perdre mon fils
la question de est-ce que c'est pas
facile d'avoir fait tout ça et de dire
aux autres de s'engager donc un d'abord
je leur dis pas de s'engager enfin voilà
je dis je m'en ressenti aujourd'hui mon
partage aujourd'hui ce que j'ai compris
et je n'ai que ça à vendre c'est même
pas à vendre jusqu'à ça tu vois pardon
pour l'expression mais à te repasser là
c'est que sur les lignes de fond j'ai vu
que des êtres vivants et j'ai vu que de
la beauté et j'ai que j'ai vu que du
courage et moi j'ai envie de partir de
faire partie de cette équipe là et je
pense que cette question de la quelle
équipe tu as envie de faire partie de
quelle équipe tu as envie
de faire partie pardon pour la
formulation et la question du moment
est-ce que tu as envie et c'est ce que
encore ce que tu as envie d'être celle
qui regarde le train passé et qui
va se concentrer sur la prochaine paire
de baskets quoi
tu vois
où est-ce que tu as envie d'être
d'être cette personne qui qui va faire
de son mieux et tu vois c'est ce choix
quotidien qui est qui tu dois plusieurs
fois par jour
entre la peur l'inverse de la peur c'est
l'amour
et finalement moi je c'est mélatic qui
m'a dit ça et maintenant je regarde tout
à ce à ce toi je sais que c'est là la
question de l'énergie moi c'est une
forme d'énergie en fait
c'est une énergie non l'amour ouais mais
c'est la tu vois c'est pour moi c'est
l'un ou l'autre en fait et tout et tout
mille fois par 10 fois par jour 100 fois
par jour tu prends des décisions et moi
je ne vais plus que ce filtre là la peur
l'amour le confort l'humanité
le SDF dans la rue tu passes devant tu
donnes une pièce tu fais un sourire tu
t'assois 2 secondes la façon dont tu
réponds tes enfants la façon dont tu vas
accueillir tel ou telle parole tu vois
et je dis pas que j'arrive à être tous
les jours dans l'humanité ou dans
l'amour tu vois mais pour moi une
journée réussie
c'est une journée ou tu vois s'il y a eu
100 fois cette question et elle est dans
tous les actes du quotidien
et ben c'est une journée où 50% ou 55 %,
j'ai répondu par l'humanité ou par la
mort ça c'est une journée réussie
question Internet et si vous livre se
retrouver en téléchargement libre en
téléchargement libre au nom du droit à
l'accès à la culture j'aimerais bien
c'est
faut m'aider à le faire mais je pense
que sur je suis sûr qu'Olivier frebour
qui m'entend là ce serait d'accord de
libérer le livre c'est prêt on a les
fichiers
ça c'est hyper facile et j'ai même envie
de te dire moi ce que mon rêve c'est pas
seulement les livres il a raison ouais
il a raison moi je voudrais libérer big
girls en fait parce que ce qui me tue en
ce moment c'est que quand
j'ai fait une erreur
enfin je sais pas si c'est une erreur
j'apprends le jour où j'aurais tout
compris je pense que ça sera la fin mais
de ma vie mais donc j'espère que c'est
pas tout de suite tout de suite quand
même mais j'aimerais bien encore
expérimenter deux trois trucs mais
quelque chose que j'aimerais beaucoup
libérer c'est big girls et Arte je le
redis a décidé de libérer meeting Stones
normalement enfin bon c'est et
moi ça me ça m'énerve que tu vois des
gens dans les écoles les enfants et à
payer pour voir mon film alors les
internautes vont encore dire ah mais
elle se fait là
il y a rien à gagner là-dedans enfin tu
vois il y a des il y a des contenus qui
sont pas faits pour être payant quoi et
je pense que la question c'est qu'on vit
dans un mode d'argent donc comment je
finance mes films ça c'est la vraie
question
d'internet qui a besoin d'une petite
précision pour Michael 42 c'est 35000
euros par an ou par mois
c'est Mickaël
est-ce que tu vois un sujet que tu
aimerais aborder avec nous
ah non question internet peut-on être
humble tout en étant vaniteux
merci mais
je pense qu'il faut beaucoup de
prétentions pour faire ce que je fais et
peut-être que tu fais c'est à dire je
crois qu'il faut beaucoup de prétentions
de mégalomanie pour croire que ce qu'on
a à dire est important j'ai rien à dire
je monte pas ma tête
je vais parler de moi tu as raison je te
mettais dans le sorry je pense qu'il
faut beaucoup de prétention pour faire
ce que je fais tu vois qu'est-ce qui me
fait croire que ce que j'ai à dire est
intéressant
donc il faut il faut à la fois beaucoup
de prétention et à la fois faut beaucoup
d'humilité parce que
parce que c'est pas de moi donc il
s'agit quoi enfin tu vois je
sais que
c'est une super bonne question
tu vois ce film s'appelle big years il
veut ça veut dire plein de choses ça
donne quoi
alors littéralement ça voudrait dire
plus grand que nous
plus poétiquement c'est vivre en grand
vivre en grand
mais il y a cette question que je leur
ai tous posé tu vois quand je les ai
rencontrés qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
pourquoi pour toi big girlshan US et au
fond bien sûr question que tu vois
n'importe qui aurait posé pourquoi tu
fais ça toi
une façon d'absoudre ton âme de faire ça
pour moi c'est surtout une façon
d'absoudre ma colère et de faire quelque
chose de ma colère
de mon âme
de mon âme en peine ouais c'est ouais
c'est sûr
tous alors ils sont pas imaginés
je sais pas comment il s'appelle c'est
pas un Dieu je crois que
ouais je crois que il y a quelque chose
qui passe à travers nous je crois que
enfin
et je crois que parfois ce que j'écris
ou ce que je dis tu vois probablement là
c'est pas vraiment moi qui parle
d'ailleurs je n'oserais jamais regarder
cette interview
ouais je regarderai les autres d'accord
oui mais
et c'est super Quand tu es dans cet état
quel soulagement de pas être soi tu vois
qu'elle soulagement de se rendre compte
que parfois on peut être au service de
quelque chose et c'est et c'est ce c'est
pour ça que je voulais te parler de ça
donc là à la question
pourquoi tu fais ça tu vois je l'aurais
tous posé la question parce que
effectivement c'est la question que tu
me poses c'est la question que je me
pose c'est la question
et ils m'ont tous parlé de spiritualité
finalement sans avoir les mots donc il y
en avait qui était tu vois les
africaines étaient vraiment très
connectée à Dieu probablement que moi
Mad avait aussi un Dieu
mais tu vois il le nommait pas
nécessairement il disait c'est plus fort
que moi je le fais parce que c'est plus
fort que moi
aussi tu vois cette ententement Bigard
et là je voudrais vraiment si tu me
permets enchaîner et vas-y pourquoi
tu as dit que j'étais à la maison je le
prends
pourquoi c'est possible en fait
et c'est pour ça la question sur la
vanité elle est très très importante
c'est possible parce que ils ont réussi
à mettre l'ego dans un petit boîte qui
vient plus les déranger
c'est à dire l'ego c'est la volonté de
plaire la volonté de séduire la volonté
d'être conforme la volonté d'être aimé
la volonté de pas décevoir
la peur d'être regardée par les autres
la peur la peur la peur la peur la peur
tu vois et à partir du moment où tu
arrives à peu près donc tu es ça et moi
j'y arrive pas toujours tu vois
et bien tu te connectes en fait à
quelque chose de plus grand que toi
c'est le c'est le sinequanone si tu
restes si tu restes avec l'idée que ça
va te faire des views que ça te faire
des clics à faire des likes tu vois
c'est super merci enfin bravo pour tout
ce que tu fais pour non mais tu vois
même
on met pas de pub on est financé
uniquement par notre communauté
de TV en dans tout de suite et tu payes
tes impôts en France je sais que c'est
un sujet important
mais tu vois cette ce truc là c'est
c'est vraiment c'est très très important
parce que parce que la question de la
vanité en fait
dans ce film moi j'ai été très challenge
et par mon ego on a été au Festival de
Cannes on est sorti aussi au cinéma il y
a la bataille des chiffres il y a la
compète il y a qui sort le premier tu
vois c'est toujours la bataille de la
récré qui est-ce qui fait pipi le plus
loin tu vois enfin pardon mais et ben ça
t'abîme
ça dans ces moments là c'est les seuls
moments où je suis malheureuse en fait
les seuls moments où ça me rend mal ça
me met mal c'est ça et dès que je sors
de ce truc là et il faut quand même faut
quand même
bien ancré parce que parce que toute la
société est fait pour que tu sois
rattrapé par ces trucs là combien tu as
de like est-ce que il y a les gens qui
te suivent sur insta est-ce que machin
et je suis pas émue à ça mais quand tu
arrives à dégager ça tu te connectes et
ça c'est un truc que j'ai appris de et
c'est cette c'est en fait je m'excuse
d'insister mais au-delà de ma personne
c'est hyper important et notamment dans
les questions d'engagement il y a trop
de gens qui rentrent qui font des qui
deviennent bénévoles dans des assos
parce qu'ils sont persuadés qui vont
changer le monde parce qu'il
s'impliquent il s'implique parce que
demain matin il va y avoir un impact
précisément moi je verrai jamais
l'impact de ce que je fais et en fait il
faut jamais que je me pose la question
ce que je suis en train de faire c'est
parler à deux personnes qui vont parler
à trois personnes qui ont parlé à 5
personnes et peut-être qu'au bout du
bout du bout tu te souviens ta question
est-ce que tu crois au changement je
pense que c'est une mauvaise question si
je vais là-dedans je vais dans l'ego
c'est une mauvaise question pour moi tu
vois c'est un truc ou en fait c'est un
show strap c'est un truc où je vais être
piégé je vais arrêter de réfléchir parce
que bien sûr c'est désuet à ce qu'on
fait c'est désuet et en même temps c'est
hyper puissant remettre un petit bout de
flamme dans l'oeil d'un enfant qui
arrive dans une projection les pieds
d'entraîner par sa prof qui a pas envie
d'être là qui commence par râler parce
qu'une heure 36 ont un film c'est
impossible et qui sort de là en disant
bon bah ok donc est-ce que je peux
qu'est-ce que je peux faire
c'est énorme en fait tu vois mais c'est
pas quantifiable parce qu'il y a pas une
valeur tu as pas un chiffre tu as pas un
truc tu vois donc la plupart des gens ma
cocotte ça crache pas ton histoire et
ben si tu sors de si tu es piégé par ton
égo tu t'arrêtes tout de suite tu vois
et si tu te dis bah en fait il y a
quelque chose de plus grand qui passe à
travers ça et moi c'est ce que je sais
faire
et c'est un travail pardon pour ce mot
de l'amour tu vois l'expression
américaine labor of Love si tu te mets
la dent bah tu es peut-être perché
peut-être que 50% sont en train de
décrocher et ben les autres 50% ils
disent
c'est peut-être une vraie source
d'énergie quoi
pardon excuse-moi parce que j'ai pas
fini mon point il y a trop de gens qui
rentrent dans l'engagement parce qu'ils
pensent qu'ils vont changer le monde
c'est des mauvaises raisons de s'engager
c'est de l'ego c'est de l'orgueil et ces
gens-là finissent en burnout dans les
six mois
on va on s'engage pas pour changer le
monde on s'engage pour vivre dignement
et pour trouver sa communauté et
probablement
t'es foutu de ma gueule tout à l'heure
une aventure non mais tu as dit une
aventure c'est la star ac
j'ai l'impression d'entendre la
dialectique c'est-à-dire que la Star Ac
a repris tout à l'heure je sais pas si
tu te souviens quand j'ai dit ouais
voilà bah ouais mais
je veux
mais mais c'est pour ça c'est je
voudrais justement dire qu'on a tu vois
on a parlé on parle d'engagement avec
les mauvais termes on parle d'engagement
soit pour dire j'y vais parce que je
suis fort je vais changer les trucs soit
on dit ça soit on dit j'y vais par
culpabilité parce qu'il faut bien que je
fasse quelque chose parce que j'ai
privilège c'est deux trucs là sont des
très mauvaises raisons de s'engager
dans les six mois tu as fait un burnout
dans les six mois tu es déçu parce que
précisément tu ne verras pas l'impact il
y a un exercice d'humilité c'est
l'engagement ça marche pas tu as le
monde entier contre toi tout le monde te
traite dîner d'idéaliste doux rêveur de
tu vois tu dis tu vois ce que je veux
dire c'est vraiment c'est un chemin de
croix quoi mais dans ce chemin de croix
tu rencontres des gens formidables tu te
lis tu fais des rencontres de ouf
regarde-moi comment j'ai rebondi non
mais ça jamais je l'aurais vécu si
bien sûr regarde le trajet que tu fais
quand on a lancé le truc ah non mais
deux heures
ils veulent du simple et court tu
comprends t'es bien rigolo
aussi avec un énorme mépris pour les
gens
comme les gens c'est comme si les
personnes qui étaient là étaient pas
capables de comprendre quoi
[Musique]
on arrive à la fin de notre interview
est-ce que tu veux aborder quelque chose
qu'on a pas abordé ou un éclair de
lucidité que tu voudrais nous
ça fait ton taf merci quoi
non mais je voudrais
accordé x temps
c'est gentil la communauté ouais mais tu
vois ce que tu enfin non mais vous allez
encore
se [__] de ma gueule mais tant pis
mais c'est de l'amour quoi et c'est
l'amour
trois bouquins trois bouquins
passionné ou qui qui t'ont fait voyager
[Musique]
du monde ou pas
bon alors je démarre par un classique
des classiques Voyage au bout de la nuit
parce qu'il y a une scène enfin il y a
un moment qui m'a ému
où il y a des femmes qui se rendent au
chevet de blessé de guerre mutilés etc
et qui écrivent qui demande aux mutilés
de guerre de raconter ce qu'ils ont vécu
et voilà c'est le pour leur redonner une
dignité pour après tu vois essayer de
retrouver leur famille etc et donc c'est
probablement un lien enfin tu vois tu me
sors ça c'est probablement en lien avec
je crois la puissance de l'écrit la
puissance du témoignage et ce que ça
fait de d'aller capter l'histoire de
quelqu'un en fait quand tu quand tu
finalement quand tu quand tu écoutes
quelqu'un profondément c'est de la
dignité quoi donc ça première chose
deuxième livre que j'ai adoré daveger
plus grand auteur américain vivant il a
mon âge je dirais pas le tien
il est auteur il est militant il est
activiste il a écrit un livre qui est
extraordinaire pour comprendre
la crise migratoire qui s'appelle le
grand quoi what is awate extraordinaire
bouquin non seulement sur la forme et
sur le fond il est écrit avec un réfugié
soudanais qui s'appelle Valentino
atchadang dont il dont il raconte
l'histoire et il a reversé 50 % bien sûr
il partage bien sûr c'est c'est droit
d'auteur avec Valentino qui a construit
des bibliothèques et des écoles enfin si
tu veux j'adore ces trucs ou c'est bien
plus qu'un livre c'est bien plus qu'une
histoire tu vois tu es toujours la
question c'est bien plus c'est bigger
que
deuxième troisième
parce que c'est toi
tase zone d'autonomie temporaire de
Hakim bai penseur de la de la théorie
insurrectionniste
il explique en fait que c'est le site à
chaque fois mais parce que je pense que
c'est un tout petit livre qui est clé
enfin pour moi il était clé il explique
ce que c'est que la liberté tu sais on
les avait vendu la liberté ce truc on
est dans des pays libres dès les années
70 il attendait les cocos c'est pas du
tout ce qui est en train de se passer en
fait on est dans un
océan de contrainte nous sommes des
flibustiers sur des bateaux et la
liberté c'est des îlots comme ce que tu
viens de m'offrir en fait on vient de
vivre une tasse une zone d'autonomie
temporaire tu as créé un espace comme un
îlot de liberté dans lequel j'ai pu dire
tout ce que j'avais à dire
c'était joyeux ça a été éphémère lui il
rajoute orgeac et c'était et c'est
destiné à se refermer pour qu'après toi
et moi on repartonne petite esquif
sur cet océandre contrainte jusqu'à
cette prochaine espace de liberté et
depuis que j'ai lu ça je comprends que
tu vois on va retourner dans notre rue
avec ces métros qui fonctionnent pas
dans cet océan de contrainte à chercher
non bah peut-être moi je l'ai pas vu
mais très bien tant mieux j'espère que
tout le monde a pu rentrer chez soi
c'est fait tout mais ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que
ces moments de liberté c'est des moments
en fait c'est les moments de joie et
c'est des moments qu'on va chercher dans
lesquels on se recharge pour après
retraverser ces moments de douleur ou de
difficultés jusqu'à prochaine truc
jusqu'à la prochaine îlot jusqu'au
prochain îlot jusqu'au prochain
tu vois il se passe qu'on va se créer et
c'est zone d'autoomi temporaire ça j'ai
jamais fait le lien mais ça me fait
penser avec ça me fait penser à quelque
chose que la maman de sud-escale
protagoniste du film Maddie puisque j'ai
interviewé les parents de ses enfants là
je suis parents moi aussi en me disant
mais comment vous avez fait des enfants
comme ça tu vois
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour nos
enfants et elle m'a dit et c'est très
bien on va finir là dessus
alors on va presque finir là dessus
toi
et bien sûr et merci mais elle a donc ma
question pour elle c'était qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire pour nos enfants
comment on peut les aider
et elle m'a parlé d'une tasse en fait
elle m'a parlé de d'espace de sécurité
de safe place elle m'a dit finalement ce
qu'on peut faire pour nos enfants mais
ce qu'on peut se faire pour les uns les
autres en fait dans ce moment si
difficile
c'est de créer des espaces de sécurité
alors psychique ou physique en tout cas
pour les enfants c'est des espaces dans
lequel ils peuvent venir
déposer leurs colères déposer leurs
larmes déposer leurs expérimentations
déposer leurs doutes déposer leurs
craintes déposées leurs pleurs se
recharger et repartir des espaces de
sécurité c'est c'est dans les familles
d'abord qu'il faut le démarrer donc
peut-être que tout à l'heure je sais pas
si je suis allée jusqu'au bout mais
si vous êtes parents que vous écoutez
cette émission
essayez d'être de créer ces espaces de
sécurité pour vos enfants pour qu'ils se
sentent autorisés à parler de leur
solitude et de leur mal-être et à sortir
de leur isolement le premier espace de
sécurité c'est dans les familles là j'en
vois sans ouvrir et je suis la première
surprise tu connais mon travail tu sais
combien j'ai tapé sur les boîtes tu sais
combien j'ai créé j'ai dénoncé les
systèmes de collusion les paradis
fiscaux enfin les manipulations de
Goldman Sachs tu sais combien et combien
j'ai payé pour ça tu le sais
j'ai pas eu de contrefiscale mais c'est
vrai qu'avec 35000 dollars enfin bon
bref euro pardon c'est vrai que ils font
perdre leur temps mais
moi un jour j'ai trouvé un truc bizarre
chez moi les portes ouvertes bizarrement
mon bureau allumé alors que je suis
parti en weekend tu vois j'ai eu ça
je crois que j'ai je crois que j'ai été
intimidé mais
est-ce que ça
peut-être tu vois tu sais quoi je vais
leur dire merci parce que peut-être ça
m'a fait flipper
et ça m'a montré que fallait peut-être
que je passe à autre chose et que dans
la dénonciation et j'étais non seulement
sur une mauvaise voix pour moi parce que
ça me faisait mal je me suis vraiment
abîmée j'étais Dark et aussi parce que
j'allais peut-être il essaie plus que ça
tu vois et peut-être que c'est ce qui
m'a encouragé à aller du côté de la
lumière tu vois et à me dire bah ouais
finalement tu vois le truc le plus
subversif qu'on puisse dire aujourd'hui
c'est que l'engagement c'est la joie
tu parles d'enfants
imagine toi tu as 25 ans
tu as pas d'enfant mais tu sais
ce qui est est-ce que tu referais les
enfants
ouais alors sans hésiter tu sais
pourquoi parce que j'ai les deux enfants
les plus merveilleux de la terre est-ce
que tu conseillerais aux gens de faire
des enfants
pour dire ça
je peux juste dire que moi je refais
parce que mes enfants sont les deux
êtres les plus merveilleux de la terre
que j'ai jamais rencontré de guide
pareil que c'est une que c'est mais
ouais c'est mes guides c'est mes c'est
ma source de joie la plus importante que
pour eux je ferais tout que c'est ce qui
donne un sens à ma vie alors je sais que
c'est ridicule dit ça mais mais de façon
alors là je suis dans l'égoïsme est-ce
que je culpabilise d'avoir fait des
enfants non non parce qu'ils sont ceux
qui sont
parce qu'ils sont
parce qu'ils sont heureux d'être en vie
ouais parce qu'ils sont ce qui sont et
après bon ok alors là je vais vraiment
faire rigoler tout le monde
mais
je pense qu'on je pense qu'on t'a vu ce
film qui s'appelle ça
c'est un dessin animé c'est un Pixar
si vous avez des enfants regardez ça
il raconte après vice et versa qui est
vraiment il y a beaucoup de fait il faut
les regarder parce qu'ils ont tout
compris quoi
mais même la Reine des Neiges 2 c'est la
première fois je crois si si si je te
jure mais il y a tellement de ils
essaient de tellement sauver les moments
en fait la saule en fait ils expliquent
que la ils appliquent ils expliquent
l'incarnation ils expliquent à des
enfants
tu m'as bien lu
ils expliquent à des enfants qu'en fait
ce qui se passe enfin voilà c'est que
probablement peut-être d'après on
choisit de venir sur Terre voir on
choisit nos parents c'est encore un film
de propagande qu'est-ce qui n'est pas
propagande mais non mais tu sais et moi
je suis pas loin de penser que nos
enfants nous choisissons
c'est un débat qu'on n'aura pas
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
quelque chose d'intéressable une
bouteille à la mer
[Musique]
écoute tu sais alors je viens de parler
de spiritualité tu as compris que
j'ai grandi dans un dans un terrain
Catteau enfin pas catho d'ailleurs parce
que mes parents n'étaient pas ils
étaient médecins
je te rassure
mais bon je suis dans ce bain culturel
français machin etc donc je vais
toujours cette phrase du pape n'ayez pas
peur
choisissez l'amour
la peur l'amour le confort l'humanité
c'est des voilà je crois que c'est une
clé de lecture
voilà c'est moi Mad aujourd'hui ce qui
est plus grand que nous
c'est que la plupart des gens
considèrent que le confort est plus
important que l'humanité
si tu choisis l'humanité tu fais tout
basculer
merci merci
[Musique]